Four,
three,
two,
one.
Yes.
And we're alive and always,
always wonder when I see a dude with an
android,
like,
oh,
you're on that team.
People get people get so into teams,
right.
You get so into like groups that you
belong to,
like,
oh,
he's an android guy.
What does that mean about him?
Uh,
android uses a windows phone.
He's a contrarian.
Yeah.
I'm trying to be outside the box.
He's got a Henry Rollins for president
shared.
I can't pay this guy down.
What's he trying to do is Henry rollins
really run for president,
gets a part of this merchandise.
I feel a little bit bad about that,
but yeah,
I don't think he gives a shit.
No,
I don't think he gives a shit,
but I did buy it sort of excitedly and
then had a motive,
like,
wait a minute.
So yeah.
Yeah.
He,
I don't even think he probably knows.
No,
I would,
I would imagine he might.
Maybe we'll find out now.
But uh,
yeah.
How much have you paid attention to that
guy?
I'm a big fan of Henry rollins.
Henry rollins is one of the.
I've said this poor one of the gate,
like his music gave me the curse.
Start doing standup.
Really?
Absolutely.
But I was all in.
I used to go to his spoken word shows.
I'm all in on Henry.
Oh Wow.
Did you hear his podcast with Ari fear?
No,
I haven't heard that until you got to
listen to it.
He,
um,
he and already met at Edinburgh at the
fringe festival and they were talking
about travel.
Henry just picks a spot on the map.
He just like,
he goes,
okay,
me and Mar,
let's do this.
And he has his travel agent organize it.
It doesn't go with anybody.
He goes by himself.
Yeah.
Brings a laptop and a camera and some
clothes.
When I was,
I actually met him.
I've met a couple times,
but what I really met him finally,
he came to my book tour in La with his
assistant Heidi,
and he was going on a trip and say that
can't say assistant.
She gets pissed.
She's his manager,
his manager.
When she was here,
she called me the assistant.
I wasn't that guy.
That's what I mean as a person who has
an assistant.
It's not really good word.
It makes it sound like you're saying
like,
you know,
it doesn't sound with what the person
does is they keep your shit organized.
She sends a store manager,
manager.
Heidi was there and he was leaving the
next day and he didn't know where he was
going.
She,
she told him,
you need to get out of town.
I'm tired of you.
He said she booked the trip and he had
no idea where he was like,
yeah,
I don't know where I'm going.
I don't know going.
He does it all the time and he just
writes it,
goes there and he writes.
I mean he's living the life that as an
artist I would like to live if I wasn't
married with two kids.
So I've always lived.
Even before I had two kids,
like I can't live that life,
but yeah,
I can't do that either.
But he does it well.
Are you should fear said,
all right motherfucker.
You think that's strong?
I'm going to go for four months.
So Ari went for four months all
throughout Asia.
Brought no phone,
no laptop,
no nothing.
Completely lost contact with everybody.
He didn't talk to anybody.
He knew.
No agent,
no manager.
Told them all.
I'm gone for like three months and he
wound up being for.
Was he lost for the last month?
I can't just decided not to come back
yet and just did whatever.
I mean he has his comedy central and
then
he just decided,
look,
I'm going to take some time off and I'm
just going to go.
I mean,
yeah,
that sounds great.
It does,
yeah.
It sounds amazing,
but you know,
there's a lot of negotiating I'd have to
do to get away for a weekend.
I gotta I gotTa plan out like the watch
mayweather,
Mcgregor.
I had to tell my wife weeks in advance
that that night,
three hours.
Yeah.
It's like,
I was like,
you could watch it with me,
which he did,
but we,
I can't be responsible putting the kids
to bed.
I have to
spread that out and make sure and then
remind and like put,
do not book and all those things.
Yeah.
For three hours.
Getting time away when you have
responsibilities.
It's like the more things get
complicated around you,
like the Biggie,
more money,
more problems,
you know,
I mean it really get a lot of money
then.
It's a lot less problems I think.
Know about that man.
I think you still have tons of problem
if you.
But you,
I,
I don't.
I believe at that point you can sort of
create your own problems if you want to
have tons of problems.
But there are people who have a lot of
money.
I got zack down the roaches,
somebody else.
I'm a big fan of rage against machine.
That dude like made his rage against
machine money and it was just peaced out
like,
you know,
he's a different cat.
That's what I mean.
But I like he sort of like,
I mean I'm not saying it doesn't
problems but Tom Morello probably has
more problems cause he's trying to like
I'm starting to band with Chuck d and
The guy from Cypress Hill and I'm also
releasing a solo and I'm also on tour
with the e street band.
Like that's a lot of problems.
Whereas whereas Zach's like every,
every now and again I'll go with rage
against machine and pick up that big
check.
Other than that,
I'm going back to La.
I mean,
you know,
so for me there's a level of money you
can get where you can sort of just turn
the volume way the guy can.
Calvin and Hobbes is another dude like
you know,
the chemistry of Calvin and Hobbes was
the biggest comic strip in it.
Like at that time,
people loved it.
People worshiped at some point after 10
years like I'm done and hasn't been seen
since.
That's a good move.
If you could pull it off,
that's my,
that's my goal.
That's my goal.
My goal is to get to that place of like
there's something,
I don't know what the number is,
but I feel like there's some number
where you go,
okay,
that's the number where I can put it in
the thing and the,
in the,
in the index things and they sits there
to just.
And Yeah,
I'll be gone stockpile and then
disconnect.
Good luck everybody.
Yeah.
And maybe still like the thing is every
now and again you sort of pop up to go,
hey everybody,
but I don't,
I don't have the need for the attention
part of it.
It's like a,
you know,
I liked the work I do and I want to do
the work I like to do,
but I don't have any need for the star
part of it.
Yeah.
That's,
that becomes a real problem.
Way better off with the resources,
but no star.
Yeah.
We just go to the mall.
Nobody fucks with.
It's like the,
it's like the guy next to oprah who
nobody knows their
husband.
There's also another guy,
some white guy who's like,
just the guy who maybe he's the
assistant or the manager.
I don't know what the name is,
but yeah,
there's this,
these people who were like,
hey,
you go do the thing and I'll be here.
Yeah.
Well that's a good move if you're like,
if Oprah,
because oprah is such a huge figure that
nobody's paying attention to you.
They're so focused on her,
you know,
if you're two steps behind,
you're good.
Yeah.
Anonymous slide around.
Yeah,
no,
it's real.
I'm a,
yeah,
for a project I worked on,
I actually met Oprah for this thing and
if there's a whole team of people who
are like,
it's like
a 40 year old white women who feel like
they're in the Israeli army,
like we will take you down if we need
to,
and then oprah floats to the room like
this happy beam of light and they're
like the ones who were like,
no,
we'll take care of it if it's a problem,
but you got to be intensive here around
a person like that.
Imagine how many people are trying to
grab at Oprah.
I mean,
I'm sure you get crazy like requests and
bullshit all day.
Imagine what it is to be Oprah.
I can't.
Yeah,
see.
And that's what I see if I got to
oprah's level and she's like mean she's
doing a great work.
She's the own.
There's like she's helping bring other
people up.
She started after the.
If I had done that show,
I'd be like,
good luck everybody.
I don't know.
I don't have that level of trying to be
in the thing.
She's got so much power.
She kept Dr Oz on TV after they brought
them into congress because he was lying
about miracle weight loss.
Dr Phil still has to show that she's
making money off of the Dr. Phil never
had like a scandal,
like no,
but I just feel like he's quietly.
It's like,
it's not like he was a big deal at one
right now.
He's like,
he still like you turn it on.
Oh,
he's still on.
Yeah,
and she's sitting in her chair break.
Yeah.
If you're like a housewife and you're
sitting at home and you know,
you want to find out what's wrong with
the teenage kid.
Oprah got sued by meat,
you know what I mean?
Like you and she was on her show and she
said,
I'm not gonna eat meat anymore because
of red meat.
And it was a whole thing day.
It was a,
there was a,
some sort of like when I was a court
case.
Yeah,
it was somebody's gonna have to go say
something.
He said on the show.
She basically.
I must've been about a particular
company,
but she said something about not eating
red meat anymore.
This was back in the nineties and then I
think that's how she met Dr Phil because
he was like a jury consultant.
I know too much,
but yeah.
Interesting.
Oprah Winfrey versus the beef people in
98.
President George Bush.
Wow.
I did not like Broccoli.
I have not liked it since.
This is a little different people
things.
This isn't live,
so yeah.
This is an audio story that you should
listen to,
but they're just interesting.
Interesting.
Yeah.
So she got sued about beat.
Who fucks odor?
Some Meat Corporation in Texas because
she had.
She actually had to move her show to
Texas because she was like testifying.
Yeah.
What did just say?
I wonder what it was that she says
something on the show about like,
I don't think I'll eat meat anymore or
something,
but you can't say that I don't like.
I'm not quoting her directly,
but it was something about a.
It was the mad cow bla bla bla.
Oh,
was that it?
Veggie libel laws.
I was at least some weird shit.
They only have in Texas,
probably brought her to Texas.
I didn't move her whole show to Texas
because shoot above.
Meanwhile,
have you watched.
I posted a youtube video on twitter
earlier today that shows the contrast
between what Houston used to look like
versus what it looks like now.
Holy Shit,
it's still raining there today.
Still raining there.
That's the thing.
People in understanding.
My family's from Alabama,
so I know how hurricanes work.
The hurricane hits.
That's bad because it things down and
knocks buildings over,
but then the water rises,
so that's when it gets.
That's the most of the damage done.
It's done from the flood.
That happens after the hurricane,
flood and then mold and fungus.
Like a lot of times you have to destroy
houses just because they get ate up with
black mold.
Like look at the beginning.
If you bring it to the beginning,
Jamie,
and it'll show what Houston used to look
like.
Like,
look at this.
You can see the river and now look at
this,
and then it keeps going.
This is fucking insane.
It's insane.
Just the river.
Houston is the city that many hurricane
Katrina survivors from New Orleans went
to.
Yeah,
so if you're.
And some of them couldn't go back
because in New Orleans,
New Orleans never got rebuilt and a lot
of ways and so there's people in Houston
right now who moved there because of
Hurricane Katrina and this happens.
Why?
Remember I went to Houston like six
months after Hurricane Katrina and there
was a ton of people that were,
that had to move that we're stuck there
that will like piled up together in
houses like many families and small
houses.
Did you hear that Joel osteen thing that
fucking
dare you?
He lives in a basketball arena.
I mean he doesn't live there,
but his church is the old Houston
Rockets basketball and it's elevated.
It's got 16,000 room for like 16 to
18,000 people in there.
Won't bring people and now he has got
internet shame.
This is,
that's all I remember.
Sometimes Internet shaming.
It's okay.
Sometimes it works.
So are these,
the people that are in there now?
That's just how big it is.
That's how he bought the place where the
Houston Rockets used to the churches in
a basketball arena and it's all about
the prosperity Gospel,
but he put up a link to donate money for
the flood,
went to him.
It wasn't the Red Cross and he was like,
after he got Internet the first time you
put a blink,
donate money for the flood relief here
and it was just the link on his website.
It was just a donate to his church.
He's so sketchy.
Yeah.
So sketchy man.
When you're making billions of.
I mean how long,
how much cheese making,
but you're making that much money for
the Lord and how much tax free tax free.
That's the thing because he's right
because it's a church.
That's terrific.
Yeah,
so he's making twice the money that
people have that level of.
Come on.
That's so scary.
Yeah.
Well that's like when you found out the
scientology doesn't have to pay taxes,
just like,
wait,
why?
Well it's all.
I mean,
you know,
it's all a bit like you should know if
they're not taking.
Paying text doesn't make any sense.
No,
it's completely sketchy.
There it is that his,
uh,
his,
his page on his website A.
Yeah.
So Houston give now to him.
You know,
I'm going to take a little piece.
Yeah.
Well I gotta I gotta overhead.
I can't website bills that handles this.
I got to pay him.
I got a manager and an assistant tricity
Internet connection server fees to get
this page built.
I'd have somebody do this page.
Yeah,
like three of that was so,
like just,
I mean just so tone deaf to send out
thoughts and prayers.
Dude,
you got money,
you got a fuck load of money and it all
comes from preaching the word.
So yeah.
So you first send out that link and then
people said no,
and then he said it and now the doors
are open and now they're taking liquids.
Doors are open.
We receiving anyone who needs shelter.
And let's be clear,
there was apparently somebody tweeted
out that there was like all the mosques
in Houston had opened their doors
already and we're talking.
Yeah.
So you know,
America,
those guys,
they just too much money involved.
When you stay at like does Joel Olsteen?
He must drive like some crazy car too,
right?
Yeah.
I'm sure he has many creative.
Find out what Joel Olsteen drives.
I want to know what he drives.
I guarantee you it's not even a
cadillac.
Right?
It's probably like some ridiculous
Bentley or something.
Something stupid with like a,
a golden cross on the hood.
That's the Prosperity Gospel.
If the preachers rich,
then we're all rich.
That's the.
Is that what he's preaching?
It's called the Prosperity Gospel and
it's not just him.
There's several southern evangelical
preacher.
It's called the prosperity ministry
where you preach that if I do well then
you're doing well through me.
Ooh.
Yeah.
And then you'll eventually,
eventually you'll do.
Well eventually it'll come to you,
but it's about the.
Why would you want the preacher to look
bad if.
Because the preacher is the
representative of God.
Oh yeah.
I saw one where this guy was talking
about people that have no money,
that if you have no money,
if you donate whatever you can,
even if you have no money,
the Lord will pay you back tenfold.
Yeah,
that's,
that's exactly the thing.
That's exactly.
Yeah.
It's totally ruthless and it and those.
Of course,
those people end up falling for their
scandal.
I mean,
it's the same PTI or the uh,
Tammy Faye Bakker Chin banker.
Yeah.
It's just so ruthless to go dollar
grief.
Dollar dollars.
Awesome.
It's kind of like hot dogs in the back
of his neck,
back of his neck was like these big
thick roles.
My favorite is Robert Tilden.
The guy would talks in tongues.
He said this once.
He goes,
every time you write a check to me,
Satan gets a black guy.
Did you find a car for Joel Olsteen?
He must have some bomber vehicles.
Not.
I kept trying to find a better,
like official,
but like these Ferrari's are coming up.
Oh,
there you go.
Not officially his.
It doesn't like he's not in it,
but.
Wait,
what about that one?
The one that's in front?
Yeah,
there you go.
Oh,
he lives in river oaks in Houston.
Maybe that's his house.
Put My card down on the left.
That the not.
That's really him or not.
It's too small and it doesn't.
Oh yeah.
Doesn't look like him trying harder.
I'll try to find it.
Don't worry about it.
Forget it.
We have to crack the mystery.
Nit picky.
He's doing fine.
If he doesn't own a car and he's still
doing fine.
Yeah.
He's managed to rake up ungodly sums of
money and do so without too much
scandal.
No,
no.
Yeah,
no,
he's.
But the money should be the scandal,
you know,
like I think that's the,
the fact that,
you know,
and it's because,
the whole God thing is caught up in our
government.
So there's people in our government who
feel like,
yeah,
he's doing that.
This helps me out.
You know,
I can't,
I can't be mad at him because I'm trying
to be like him.
I think had happened during the Reagan
administration.
That's when they first started bringing
in those
right wing evangelical people and making
them a part of the Republican Party and
a part of the campaigns and those people
all claimed to have people who follow
them.
So you want them,
you want them to support you.
And so yeah,
and they will and they will like
loyally.
It's a very creepy situation because
it's,
if you can tap into that market,
I mean if you can tap into that market
now it isn't.
Market isn't really clearly is.
I mean it's nothing more than that
because if they had real integrity,
they would leave it out and they,
you know,
they wouldn't go after those people and
try to use those people to win.
Oh No,
these people are doing God's work.
Let's just help them and prop them up
and leave them alone.
No,
no,
no.
There are a pawn the pawn in this whole
little silly game,
this game that's got ridiculous.
Like where do we,
where are we right now?
Like,
but now that you have your show,
you're CNN show,
I mean you're on CNN so you won't see it
in.
Do you get a fake news?
Yeah.
Do you get that?
Do you get people claiming that you're a
part of fake news?
Yeah,
I mean,
yes,
but not any.
I mean just like I'm caught up in the
storm,
like,
you know,
it's not like it doesn't always come and
meet with somebody was like,
I did something.
It's almost like another cnn fake news
journalist and I was like,
hold on,
I'm not a journalist.
I'll take the fake news part,
but I'm not actually a journalist.
Standup comedians.
Stupid.
Yeah.
So I mean I get caught up in it,
but I think yeah,
I mean I don't,
it's not coming to me in a way it's
coming to other people,
but I,
I.
The bigger thing for me is that when I
took the job at CNN is that a lot,
because I live in the bay area,
so a lot.
I was like,
what are my friends gonna think CNN is
not as much as the right ones to say.
They're the liberal news media to my
friends.
They're not the liberal news media,
you know?
So what is it to your friends?
I'm very middle of the road,
probably leaning to the right.
CNN leans to the right.
Yeah,
yes.
Yeah.
Who the fuck are you hanging out with?
I live in the bay area,
man.
I was out there on Sunday and the rally
mascot
blocks.
What's the point of that?
I went out there with my face.
Look at that.
Look at this celebrity star who showed
up at the rally.
Yeah.
No,
I.
Yeah,
so because I,
you know,
I know the people who started black
lives matter.
I know the people who they don't look at
CNN go,
this is the liberal news media.
You know?
Isn't that funny?
It's all perspective,
right?
Yeah.
And I'm not.
There are lots of perspectives at CNN
and CNN doesn't tell me to make it.
They don't tell me to do anything other
than what I'm doing.
I want to be clear about that,
but I'm saying the perception from
people,
I think it's funny like some people see
it as the liberal news media and then I
have friends who see it as as maybe the
center,
but definitely but also or leading to
the left or lean to the right and I'm
just like,
well,
you know,
I'm in there and I'm not doing anything
different because I'm there.
Well,
you have a different perspective also
because you have essentially an
entertainment show.
Same as Anthony Bordain,
essentially an entertainment Anthony
Bourdain show made my show possible that
be there without any antibody.
Well,
really Jeff Zucker,
Jeff Zucker is a brilliant guy and I was
working under him when I was doing
Fairfax factor.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I got to meet him.
He's very,
very smart guy and that was a brilliant
move to have things other than these
shows that just continually show over
and over again.
The collusion,
Russia,
collusion with Russia,
Russia.
Like now it's just like a Houston over
and over,
like you know the sac.
Look at this,
look at this rain over and over again at
anytime during your show.
That's one thing.
They'll be on news network.
Anytime some shit goes down,
they will bump your show.
Like if I record your show and then I'll
go to what's this Russia.
We have been.
People think we've been bumped more than
we have.
Sunday nights is the best night to be on
the news because the news things don't
happen,
but we've been bumped for the Orlando
shooter,
which our episode was in Florida that
week.
I was like,
yeah,
let's take us off the air.
Like you know,
I don't want to be looking like,
look at how fun it is in Florida.
We did a spring break episode.
It's like that's not what I know.
And then we got bumped the last episode
of the season got bumped the camera
where it probably Russia.
I don't remember what it's for,
but yeah,
so we've been bumped twice,
but the people who really hit it,
like the history of comedy was on CNN on
Thursdays.
Don't be on Thursdays.
Yeah.
Thursdays the world is happening.
Trump is tweeting,
you know,
things are,
things are going on in there and people
are more likely to pay attention to
breaking news on a Thursday and a
Sunday.
Like it doesn't have to be.
People are still keyed into what's
happening today,
whereas on Sunday we're all sort of like
a take a break.
I think a lot of people thought that
when trump got into office he would stop
with all the insult tweets and with all
the stuff that made him a popular
person.
Yeah.
And then all of a sudden it went from
being like something that like,
look at this guy.
He doesn't give a fuck.
Look at him.
He's running for president,
man,
he's going to win.
I think he's good.
He's our guy.
And then all of a sudden they're like,
hey,
you're still here.
You're still.
I mean,
even right now,
a midst all of his sort of somewhat.
Okay.
Presidential Style tweets about Houston.
There are tweets about his enemies.
He can't even like take that.
Let me just not enemy tweet right now.
He's still in the middle of talking
about these things be well,
uh,
Obama just sent out a tweet like,
hey,
everybody support the Red Cross.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like that.
Where's that tweet?
You know,
so.
Well he doesn't,
you know,
Obama,
obviously it doesn't have to do anything
and everything he does because it can be
completely from his own thoughts and he
doesn't,
he doesn't have an agenda.
Yeah.
But I think that,
I mean,
again,
I guess I know people who were like,
maybe it's time to have some thoughts in
an agenda as we were sort of in a Bama.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like there's a written article that said
I didn't read the article with the
headline,
said something.
Be honest about this.
Obama,
the,
the thought is that he's going to come
back in the fall to help rebuild the
Democratic Party.
And I feel like we don't,
if we're going to be here in the fall,
you know,
what,
why are you waiting?
What's going to.
Why aren't you here?
Why,
why put that off?
Like things are happening now.
You know,
now I get,
he's playing like that star trek chest
where it's three levels and things are
happening and he's seeing things I can't
see and he sees the matrix,
but I feel like
I'd like to see you before the fall,
even though the falls only like two
weeks away.
What could he do other than,
you know,
got a lot of money or certainly has
access to a lot of money for sure.
Which means you have a lot of him and he
has it.
He still has a lot of influence,
you know,
so I don't know what.
I don't know what he could do,
what he could do.
He could do something,
you know?
I think that,
you know,
even if you just responded to every
Donald Trump tweet,
I'd be like,
Yay.
Right.
Like I think there's,
there's,
he's amassing power for something and
maybe he's got some plan that I'll be
like,
oh my God,
you know,
but I just feel like he certainly is.
You know,
he's still one of the most influential
people on the planet.
Yet,
when you talk about like the three level
testing or multilevel chesting,
you gotta wonder like at what point in
time does a,
some sort of a candidate from the
Democratic Party arrive?
Like where are they and who are they?
And are they thinking,
you mean is it Gavin newsome?
Is it,
who is it?
I mean,
I hope it's,
I guess I'm a,
I will say this,
I think my party affiliation is
Democrat,
but I'm not somebody who's like repping
the Democratic Party is people sometimes
think I am just because I'm against
Donald Trump.
But uh,
uh,
so I would say this,
that I hope that that person is somebody
whose name we don't even know yet
because I feel like the thing that
happened with Obama as he came out of
nowhere,
and I think if you go to the usual
suspects with the way the current
stories current setup,
you're doomed.
If the electoral college is still in
place in four years,
then then we're doomed.
If we go to the usual suspects,
well Obama might've come out of nowhere,
but a lot of people were looking at him
like,
this guy here,
you got this guy,
Harvard educated,
very articulate,
good looking smooth,
clean,
clean is Joe Biden said he was.
He was calm like that was the most.
When you look at the way trump has been
responding to all these things,
how he freaks out when he gets a small
crowd in Arizona at a press conference.
I mean the.
The thing about Obama that stands out
more than anything was his composure.
Yeah.
He was.
He felt like the adult in the room,
whether you agreed with him or not
necessarily didn't agree with everything
he did.
He felt like a grownup who was making
thoughtful adult decisions that
sometimes I disagreed with,
but I knew he had thought them through.
Well,
and also one of the most important
things about being a president is the
president sort of sets the tone for the
rest of the country.
Like he represents the country.
Now when the president represents the
country and he's talking shit about
people bleeding from plastic surgery and
you know,
fake news and yelling about this and
then saying things that are just
absolutely not true,
it turned out to not be true and it's
like,
and you have to like look at it and then
you vet it out and you go,
Whoa,
homies fucking lying and all the
associating with people with known
conspiracy theorists and you know,
and white supremacists and you know,
to me it's like you're again,
you're saying you setting the tone for
the country and all those people feel
certainly embolden by him and empowered
by him in a way that is not healthy for
the country.
Well,
even if he doesn't support them,
that whole wink and a nod.
That's what I'm saying.
It's very sketchy.
You,
most of you as you know,
we know that most of communication is
nonverbal.
Yeah.
So the fact that he doesn't have to,
even if it sounds like he's saying the
right thing,
if it's not landing with the people,
he's talking about the right way.
Like if he says,
you know,
I support the blacks or whatever it is,
it's like if it doesn't feel like that
to the blacks,
then it's not.
That doesn't mean anything.
Well,
people know when you're saying something
from the heart versus when you're saying
something for damage control.
Like Charlottesville,
like when he came out after
Charlottesville and said that people
were behaving badly on all sides,
on all sides.
Did you get out Nazi that ran over a
crowd of protestors?
He,
he hit the gas and ran over other white
people.
You dumb fuck this.
This is so crazy.
So to say on all sides.
And he improvised that part.
That was not in the speech.
He,
that was his riff on all sides because
that was it.
I think it had been written for him and
he was like,
you know,
I can't,
I gotta I gotta put some magic in here
while I am of the belief that
nonviolence is always the answer and
that running around with masks on
hitting people with bike locks were
showing up with sticks and bats and the
shit that people are trying to do.
I think although their heart and their
mind might be in the right place when
you show up with,
with bulletproof vests on and helmets
and sticks,
people see that and that is an act of
aggression and the opposition is going
to show up in turn with something
similar or worse.
It escalates.
Well,
I think the problem is,
is that I was in Berkeley,
like I said in the weekend at the no
hate in the bay rally that was supposed
to,
you know,
that whoever said they were going to
show outright,
people will also be named white
supremacists.
They were going to show up like 40,000
people showed up.
But somewhere between three,
three and 4,000 people on which side?
Mostly on the side of not,
not the.
Alright,
so all told.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But it was like the,
the,
the side who was like,
not in our streets.
This is Berkeley.
We don't play this shit right.
Was way over.
Was Way bigger than the,
than the side from the white supremacy.
All right.
Side.
It was not even close as it was in
Boston.
Yeah.
So,
and the,
and overwhelmingly there was like 13
arrests and as many people pointed out
there's more rested a raider team,
you know,
like it's not,
it's not a lot of arrests and sometimes
you get arrested because they were like
listen,
get you the fuck out of here or this is,
this is a safety issue or you know,
so it's like 13 arrests and people were
injured.
No deaths thankfully.
But if you look at all the mainstream
news reports,
it's like,
it focuses on those people who,
the Antifa or the people who were the
black bloc anarchists who were there to
like fight with people and,
and for pe I was there.
There was old people there,
there was young people there,
there was,
I had a friend who was like,
yeah,
I got an alert on my phone.
It said that,
uh,
that there was a tear gas and I was in
the rally,
like there's tear gas,
like he's in the middle of the rally.
CNN or the San Francisco Chronicle is
like,
there's tear gas in Berkeley.
And he's like,
there is.
And all that stuff got played
overplayed.
And I was there.
My wife was there and it was a,
it was a very beautiful day.
Despite the,
despite the reason why the day to come
together,
well that's a real problem.
And that the media needs something to
bleed.
They need some tear gas,
they need a riot in order to get clicks.
It's just like that New York Times
article that I'd talked about with the
economy,
Mcgregor's face being completely
bloodied and fall.
No,
that's you doing that because you're
trying to sell newspapers,
not because that's what happened and you
haven't hired anybody there on staff who
actually knows the UFC or boxing or
knows combat sports.
Like that's to me it's like we need an
article about this.
Well,
and also having someone with a
perspective would go to that rally and
say,
look how many people were here that
believe in equality,
that believe in unity,
that believe in peace,
that just want to support this idea that
the community is filled with way more of
those people and the people with the
bike locks and the face masks and you're
talking about a few scrambled
individuals.
People you know.
And here's the thing about those people,
they don't show up when it's just a
beautiful day at the park.
Like you know,
nobody.
I live in Berkeley.
Nobody's walking through Brooklyn who
god is and t for about to show up to the
farmer's market.
Like those people don't show up unless
the shit hit the less they feel like the
shit is hitting the fan,
but what concerns me is that those
people,
when they're wearing the bike masks or
the the masks and the fucking vests and
the knee pads and all the shit,
that's where you get those assholes in
Charlotte that showed up with guns,
like those guys that were open carrying
and Charlotte with bulletproof vests on
walking on the street showing trigger
discipline with their finger on the
outside of the gun.
I was like,
how the fuck is this allowed and dressed
and many of them just in the military
garb.
So they looked like they were part of
the military.
It was like they were part of law
enforcement.
So you know,
like that was the real problem too is
people thought they were.
Some people were confused and thought
they were on there like they were part
for the part of law enforcement.
I think the thing,
the thing about Antifa I would say this
too,
is that the reason why Antifa even has a
room to exist is because people in those
communities don't think they can count
on the police,
you know,
because the.
There were two other
protests in Berkeley,
that's that it erupted in violence
because the police were standing by
watching it happen.
Right.
They didn't go in and break it up and
that certainly happened in
Charlottesville to what's been said,
and I don't know if this is true,
but it's been said that the police were
instructed in Berkeley to not engage
with the anarchists.
Yeah.
I don't know how that works.
I know the mayor of Berkeley,
I don't know.
And then I found this out recently that
the mayor of Berkeley is now in charge
of the police,
which I'm like then what's the point of
being the mayor?
He was in charge to achieve.
I guess the chief was interesting.
I had never heard of that before for
NATO.
Green told me that he talked to the
mayor.
He's like,
I'm not actually in charge of police,
and I'm like,
why are we listening to you talk to the
boss because how the fuck are the mayor
have enough time to be paying attention
to every single issue that the police
have to deal with when he's dealing with
every single issue that merits to deal
with.
But that means that the president is in
charge of the military sort of,
but he's.
So it's one of the things that the
president has done is sort of given the
power to the generals and that's one of
the things that the military really
enjoys about trump.
Yeah.
As opposed to any other presidents.
They feel like the handcuffs are off.
Yeah.
But I think that at the end of the day,
the president can,
you know,
Kim consult with,
if he tells the generals go do this
thing.
They have,
you know.
So I feel like that's the kind of.
I don't,
I don't.
I mean I think the president has too
much power of the president is you know,
many people have reported can launch
nukes if he wants to now.
And it would have to,
somebody would have to like violate his
order to not launch the nukes.
So I think there's too much power there.
But I do think it's weird that the
person who you elect to lead the city
isn't in charge of the,
of law enforcement.
Well,
as soon as he.
Pardon Joe Arpaio,
that's when everybody went.
Wait,
there's no.
I mean,
there's no serious debate.
The problem is now we have debate about
things that were there.
These aren't two equal sides.
There's not many sides.
There's nobody who seriously knows the
law or knows or knows what.
Joel prior history,
who believes he did was not guilty of
those things.
He bragged about the things that you're
profiling people and bragged about
abusing people.
So there's nobody to about people dying
in his prisons because they had heat
stroke.
Yes.
I mean he couldn't get cold water.
These people are out in tents at 120
degrees.
Yeah.
There's an article that somebody wrote
in.
This kid was born in Tijuana,
lived in Arizona,
and got arrested for drunk driving and
spent a year in those,
uh,
those camps,
you know,
look,
he,
he was raised in America is essentially
an American even though he was born in
the wrong patch of dirt for some people.
Yes,
he's an American.
He just got arrested for drunk driving
and did a year in this tent and was
talking about how people died around him
and talking about the food that they ate
and how ruthless that can.
And you know,
some people have this opinion of like,
Hey,
well then don't break the law,
but that,
that is a god damned convenient way to
look at it and not.
It's just not very humane and not very.
Not what we're supposed to be in this
country.
I mean,
we're not supposed to be a country that
is that.
Is that punitive with the law?
We often are.
And also we know the one thing we know
what America is,
that the law is not equally applied to
everybody.
So you know,
a rich guy,
rich white guy drove drunk driving.
He's not going to prison for a year
pilot,
which rich white guys in jail.
Unfortunately everybody.
Was it in that prison?
Was he going to the outside hot prison?
He threw a lot of people in that hot
prison and he's a cunt.
I guess I was talking nationally,
but our pilot,
but that the law is not applied equally
to everyone.
You know that we know that if you have
money in been privileged you can get out
of situations,
but that other people don't have money
and privilege can't get out of here.
I know comedians that have been arrested
in La for drunk driving,
they never did a day in jail and this
one kid who was born in Tijuana does a
year in a tent.
You know,
it's.
I mean,
look,
you shouldn't drunk drive.
No.
Yeah,
that's.
I mean I feel was the punishment.
Yeah,
you should be.
You should.
If you break the law,
there should be repercussions because
you don't have control of your body and
you're driving a deadly vehicle and you
could crash into a family.
Look,
there's a lot of real,
real,
real issues with the law.
Like I mean,
like I did,
we did an episode of united shades in
the first season about St Clinton,
about lifers in prison and St Clinton
and I talked to a lot of guys.
First of all,
none of the guys I talked to said they
didn't do it.
Everybody that talks like,
yeah,
I did it like I'm guilty of thing.
I did.
But when you heard what they did,
a lot of times you're like,
is that life in prison?
What do you get?
Like what?
There's a guy who was convicted of
robbing two banks that he,
he,
that's bad.
Let's say that's bad.
Definitely bad.
Nobody died.
Nobody got hurt.
Certainly people were traumatized by the
fact that robbed the bank.
He didn't even have a gun.
He did the thing because you could rob a
bank by just saying,
give me the money.
I have a bomb,
you know,
like whatever.
I can.
So,
but didn't have any weapons,
anything like that.
Now that's bad.
But he's like a,
he's probably in his sixties now and I
met him and he's one of the coolest
people I've
met.
He's a leader in prison.
He's one of the guys who runs the
newspaper and he invited me.
He's like,
he talked to my agent was like,
you're coming back in September to speak
to the guys.
Like he's just,
he's a total leader and he's in prison
for life for the rest of his life.
Not Joe Pile.
Yeah.
Our is directly responsible for people
being dead.
Yes.
Yeah.
There's a ton of people that have
mysteriously died inside that guy's
prisons and,
and that's,
that's the part about me.
It's like there's these.
This is not the same scales of justice
we're talking about.
I know there's a guy who got a third
strike in California because no
California third strike law that
happened for firing a gun in the air.
That's bad,
but that ended up with them getting life
in prison and you're just like,
it's bad.
It's bad.
It's not.
I feel like I'd have to say that enough.
I'm not saying let every,
every inmate out,
but I'm saying it's bad,
but life in prison.
Well,
the idea that you could never reform
people,
that's.
That seems insane.
And the.
Well,
I guess there's the other perspective is
where are the resources going to come
from to actually reform someone?
How much effort does it take?
And individual cases are different and
some people really are just habitual
criminals and there's nothing you can do
about it.
And if you do release them and they
continue to do a crime or they hurt
somebody that they didn't have to,
like where does the burden lie there?
But I,
you know,
I think Norway I believe is the country,
Jamie,
when I have to look it up,
that the longest prison prison sentences
you can get is 20 years prisoners live
in like one bedroom apartments.
Like they,
you know,
they have tv,
they have.
And the whole thing is like,
and this is San Quentin has,
is to,
there's rehab programs.
I talked to inmates who said that and
then after 20 years in Norway,
they talk to you and go,
are you ready to go back outside?
Like they don't let you out
automatically,
but they sort of checked back in with
you.
And so if you're not like the guy who
shot up the,
uh,
those people in Norway,
he's not going to get out again.
But the whole idea is that
small percentage of prisoners serve more
than 14 years.
Wow.
Yeah.
But the thing is,
they're in there like,
like in San Quintin,
uh,
I talked to inmates who said in most
California prisons,
the rehab programs are aaa and Jesus,
like that's all they have is Jesus.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So,
yeah,
just a pathway to Jesus.
But in San Quintin there's a newspaper,
there's,
there's a,
there's a restorative justice programs,
like a,
you know,
there's a plate that you can learn how
to code.
Like there's a prisoners.
We learn how to code right now so that
when you come out,
there's a sense of like I have.
So there's lots of other programs,
I can't even think of it,
but there's also,
this is yoga in St Clinton because of
the bay area.
And so there's all these things in the
so that when you come out you are a more
fully formed human being so that you
have,
you have job skills,
you've done,
you've done restorative justice
programs,
you've helped other inmates who came in
to do restorative justice programs.
So when you come out,
it's not that it's easy to get to be
paroled from prison,
you know,
but when you come out you're more
prepared for the world as opposed to
guys in other prisons in California who
get out who have just been like doing
rehab in Jesus and have no way to
interact with the world.
Yeah.
And just feel like they'd just been
punished,
like being isolated and locked in a
cage.
And it's a lot of those guys say they go
in there for one crime that's not a big
deal.
And he learned how to be in bed or
criminals in prison because you have to
sort of like,
California has like levels of prison.
I think level four is the worst and like
maybe a level five.
But anyway.
So everybody sort of starts out at a
level four.
So if you like are in prison in
California for something,
you know,
shooting a gun in the air,
you're at a level,
you're there with murderers and then you
have to survive that and hopefully
graduate to San Quintin.
But if you're in there with murderers
you have to survive that.
And so a lot of guys become bigger,
better criminals because they're
surrounded by car,
by bigger badder criminal just to put on
armor to protect yourself just to get
through the day.
And so to me like the whole,
I mean,
you know,
the,
you know and there's a lot of money
that's already in prisons that's not
being used.
Well the prison private prison system,
like we're selling private companies are
selling like they have to keep the
prisons full because they're running a
prison for profit.
So it becomes less about like,
it's like we need to keep the beds full,
you know,
it's not about like Rehab and
rehabilitations about we need to keep
the beds full because we are running,
we are a corporation running for profit.
That's where it gets dark.
How the fuck did anybody ever improved
that?
That is so scary to someone.
It's basically they're using humans as
like cells and a battery,
like a giant battery that generates
income.
Yeah,
exactly,
and that the prisoner,
it's the goal is not to turn these guys
into better citizen citizens.
The goal is to keep the the men and
women,
but the goal is to keep the prisons
filled.
Well,
it's absolutely been proven by prison
guard unions trying to.
They mean they lobby against marijuana
legalization of marijuana,
which is probably the one thing that's
going to stop people from committing
crimes.
Yeah,
I mean you're talking about violent
crimes.
If there is a drug that's going to stop
you from doing a violent crime,
that might be it,
but at least maybe like less than the
chances.
Yeah.
Maybe I should sit down and just chill
out for a second before I go do that
thing.
Yeah.
There's no other reason to lobby against
it that you want to keep your job.
You want to make sure that you have
plenty of jobs that people in your union
and the and those,
and there's many of those people who are
in prison for nonviolent drug offenses
like marijuana and other things,
who are the next to next to murderers,
you know,
you don't have to figure out how to
navigate through that and they're.
And if you're not in San Quintin,
you're not,
you're not in a place where you can
learn other skills.
I mean,
you know,
again guys,
didn't Clinton getting college diplomas,
getting like all sorts of certificates
and things,
but the problem is,
is that nobody then wants to release
them from prison.
That chance nobody will.
Nobody wants to go.
No politician goes,
I have released more inmates from
Britain.
He
takes his one.
Willie Horton,
right?
Yeah.
Which we,
you know,
and that was like,
we're again,
we're demonizing one case.
Same thing with Berkeley.
There's a picture that was on the San
Francisco Chronicle of an ever
antifungals antifa black bucket because
I don't know,
like with a,
with like a like a gas bomb it and
surrounding that person is journalists
taking pictures of him so that that
becomes the face.
It's like they're not surrounded by
other black black people.
It's like all the journals are going.
That's where the picture is.
Not like the people who were like,
I was on a on a truck with clergy
singing like spirituals.
Nobody took pictures of that and put it
on the news.
Oh,
sorry.
Kqbd there.
Do they?
Yeah,
the local public radio station,
because I'm a celebrity.
I was in the back of the truck.
Well anytime there's like some sort of a
gathering,
you're always gonna have people in that
gathering that act out,
try to get more attention than they
deserve or that get caught up in the
whole group movement.
Like there's always this sort of like
gigantic mass of people that will cause
people to behave.
Some people to behave in a way that's
uncharacteristic or.
And I mean there's just that mob
mentality.
I a real thing that happens is like,
you know,
rock concerts or anything.
Yeah,
yeah.
Mentalities 100 percent real.
You can feel it in the air when Shit's
going sideways.
I mean it happens.
I mean I've been in clubs where it's
like,
you know,
something happens like a heckler or
something.
That's the energy changes and there's
that moment of like,
what's about to happen,
you know,
it feels like.
And you also been in that position.
I'm sure you have where you feel like I
have a lot of power in this moment.
Like I could if I said
like if I go,
yeah,
if you say you certainly,
if you said get them,
people would get it.
You know what I mean?
If I said get them,
they'd be like,
I will write my congressman.
You're right,
we should start a petition.
You know,
but that's real.
That's all you know.
And I think the thing is that everybody
responds differently.
The thing that happened,
I'll say specifically in Berkeley was
that there's a sense that these people
brought violence to Berkeley the last
few times they came and people respond
differently to threats of violence.
Some people respond with the nonviolent
thing.
Some people respond to,
I won't go to the park that day and some
people respond with,
fuck it,
bring it.
Well,
don't you think there's also a real
issue in you.
I mean you got to find out what his
actual hate speech and what is like
someone like Ben Shapiro who I think is
just a conservative guy who's very
articulate and doesn't promote hate at
all and he's extremely reasonable,
but there's a lot of people that equate
him even though he's an Orthodox Jew and
a lot of people equate him with being a
Nazi and they try to silence him from
speaking.
Like when you do that,
I think it becomes a giant issue and I
think he got to let people talk and if
you disagree with people,
I mean as long as they're not out there
promoting violence or promoting
negativity or promoting some sort of a.
anything that it's a portrait,
but if you,
if you let someone talk and then if you
have someone that disagrees with them,
have a debate.
Well,
I think the Baden have everybody be
peaceful and civil with each other.
I mean,
I think the problem is,
is that the,
the,
that line of what hate speech is,
and I just talked to somebody from acl.
Ooh,
uh,
my other podcasts about,
about the whole hate speech thing.
What podcast?
Politically reactive.
Uh,
yeah.
It's a podcast with my friend,
Hari Kondabolu.
What's a weekly talk about politics?
We were going to do it.
We started it right before the election,
like we'll do this political podcast and
Hillary will win.
They will go about our business
is huge.
Hillary supporter.
But that was a figure.
That was the deal.
We were offered do it up until the
election and then it was like,
oh,
I guess we're doing this for maybe
forever,
maybe through the end of time.
So he becomes like Putin.
Yeah.
Exact.
I mean,
you know,
that's the real fear,
you know.
Although then I guess I stay employed.
I don't know,
just rock was onstage right after the
election.
He goes,
you know,
he's never getting out of there,
you know that right.
It's going to be there forever.
He scared the shit out of me because I
never thought about that.
I mean,
you know,
Bloomberg stayed in New York an extra
term just because he wanted to,
you know,
New York governor's.
Yeah,
New York.
Mayor's is supposed to be two terms and
out.
And he was like,
it was,
I forgot who it was,
but it was like he was like,
I think I understand other one and they
let him know that I didn't live in New
York at the time,
so I don't know how it all went down.
Did they change the law?
I think he changed the law.
I don't know if you changed permanently,
but yeah.
Yeah.
So if there is a precedence for this is
all I'm saying there's a precedence for
some sort of like the country needs me
because it's so divided.
Yeah.
Motherfucker.
Because you divide a bit.
Like this is how the game works.
So I would say the thing about Ben
Shapiro,
and I don't,
I've only seen a little bit of his work,
but I certainly,
I know there are people on that side who
it's an ideological argument and
ideological arguments sometimes can be
filled with hate.
So I'm not,
I don't know Ben Shapiro.
So that's,
that's sometimes it's like,
well yeah,
it's just,
you're just making ideological argument.
But it ends with me having to move out
of America,
you know,
so that's what.
But I'm saying so,
but some people make these articles.
I'm not saying him,
but the problem is,
is that now there's a whole movement
associated with things that maybe ben
looks to be a part of so that if he
shows up,
people don't know and don't know that
he's not.
That he shows up going,
I'm not bringing violence,
but they're not.
Vape may be violent traveling around
with him.
It's not him,
but there are others like him,
a war less,
less reasonable.
Like all right,
like whatever the fuck alt right is I,
I have a problem.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
Right.
And what does that,
I mean people that are on that that are
violent and there's people that are
considered themselves antifascist that
are extremely peaceful and they would
say that they're anti for the real
antifa.
And then what is black block?
What is that?
That's no granicus.
I think it's probably a bay area.
How long has that been going?
It's been going.
I think if we're going on a while,
but I don't know,
I,
but it's a thing that like whenever we
would see.
I think now we're calling it an Antifa,
but like there would be.
I mean this happened the,
there were some black lives matter
protests in Berkeley and some black
bloc.
Anika.
So it's described the same way.
We're in black all covered up.
And they were like.
And these people showed up,
so I don't know if they were in teeth,
were like,
great,
now we can loot.
And people stood in front of stores
going,
no,
we're not.
We're not doing that.
We're not,
we're not doing.
That had nothing to do with you getting
into the verizon store,
right?
Nothing to do with you ransacking this a
radio shack.
I saw some of the Antifa people trying
to stop.
One of the other Antifa people from
beating up a trump supporter.
They had this guy down and that was a
journalist Al Letson.
That's A.
Yeah,
he's a bay area journalists.
He has the podcast reveal and he's the
guy that tried to stop.
He's got.
Yeah.
Black Guy.
Waited through the white people.
Well,
there's white people that I saw doing it
too.
So it must have been like sort of a
must,
but certainly it happened more than.
Yeah,
certainly there are people who are like,
there's tea,
there's people who support it because
they feel like,
well we need somebody who stands up to
this,
but there's not people who support
people beating people up randomly.
Uh,
so yes,
there were outlets in and other people
stepped into like,
yeah,
we're not.
The thing about the Berkeley and the
berries that people don't get,
they think it's all one thing like that.
It's awesome.
Sort of like left d,
like socialist blah,
blah blah.
And the thing about Berkeley's,
it's not that the is not that it's a lot
of different people who feel like who
are on some version of the left,
but they don't necessarily agree with
each other and they let a lot of shit
go.
Like that's not like the,
you know,
so that can be the naked guy who walked
through town.
Like that doesn't mean we all support
people walk around naked.
But we're like,
oh,
was me.
But it also means that like during
Obama's reign in the bay,
I lived in San Francisco,
they were libertarian setup on corners
with Obama,
big huge pictures of Obama and with a
Hitler mustache has painted on him and
we're all like,
oh,
as long as you're not,
you don't.
You don't want to start a fight.
Well you do your thing man.
And that's what people don't get.
Who have put this whole lefty sort of
whatever lived hard thing on Berkeley.
It's not one thing.
It's not,
it's where it's a lot of things that the
berries is.
It's where all the freaks sort of end up
with.
Like I don't feel in my life that I'm
understood,
but we don't agree with each other thing
that we sort of all agree on is that you
can.
So if the alt right wanted to show up,
you know,
conservative people come speak at
Berkeley all the time.
It's specifically around people who look
like they're bringing violence or
bringing targeting people.
That's the problem.
The Berkeley,
UC Berkeley,
one of the professors I think of law
there is named John you a why?
Oh,
he wrote the Bush torture memos.
He's a professor at UC Berkeley.
Nobody's like,
we got it.
I guess he's a good professor.
You know what I mean?
What does the professor in a law,
he's a law professor and he's been there
for a long time and he's.
He wrote the Bush torture memos that
said,
you know,
if you do some waterboarding,
this is not a direct quote,
but he wrote memos.
It said like that.
It sort of outline how to do enhanced
interrogation techniques.
He's been there for a long time and
nobody thinking about him.
Go get him.
Everybody.
No,
but I mean,
I'm jokes.
I've never met him,
I've never socialized with him,
but he's there and also I'm the dude who
was a deep in the Clinton White House,
a kitten he was named,
but yeah,
there's.
It was also at Berkeley,
like there's not some sort of lefty
version of Berkeley.
That is one thing.
It's a lots of different things.
The free speech thing is true.
The thing that people are nervous about
is violence.
Yeah.
So I think that,
you know,
ann coulter can come speak at Berkeley
anytime she wants to.
If the.
If,
if there's this thing about like there's
not going,
I'm going,
I'm not going to encourage violence.
Here's the issue with Ann Coulter,
I think Ann Coulter is and opportunists
and they think that what she does is try
to inflame people so that she can sell
books and stay relevant.
It's,
it's a,
it's.
She's actually going after the market
like we were talking about earlier.
She saw this market out there.
It's like,
Oh,
I'm a pretty blonde lady.
I could,
I could probably sell.
She's a what?
I think that's how she's been at some
point.
I'm a black guy.
I can't see what are you seeing
glasses you try them on?
I feel like early in her career she was
marketed that way.
I'm not trying to say I'm not trying to.
There's a lot of those out there.
I don't think she's one of them.
Okay,
well then I'll let you be the expert,
but uh,
please do.
But I'm just saying I'm A.
I'm a blonde lady.
Okay.
Yeah,
there you go.
Then there's a lot of that.
Yeah.
That it's like that in this package,
this becomes.
It's the same way that like his comics,
he go,
Oh,
you're the guy who does this,
you know?
Yeah.
So she's doing it dot.
I mean there's people that do that
online that they,
they're saying things that are
inflammatory.
They're saying things they don't,
you don't know,
don't necessarily fear of being
completely objective and reasonable.
They wouldn't say that you're only
saying it because they think it's going
to get a reaction,
which is why her and Bill Margaret along
together because they're both doing the
same thing.
I can't deal with that.
I just don't have enough time.
Not enough time in the world.
You should get attention for what you
deserve attention for and if you want
attention by being provocative
intentionally,
unless you're funny.
That's common.
That's the nature of comedy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
it's absolutely true.
I think she thinks she's funny,
but I feel like these,
like Berkeley has had conservative
speaker speak there throughout the
history of Berkeley.
It's not about that.
It's a big history is different than the
current.
The current thing is because when,
when Milo was going to show up,
he.
There was a,
there was the fear and he'd seen it
happen before where he was targeting
students,
either undocumented students.
He like naming students during his stage
thing who are undocumented or trans,
and there was fear that like we that's
promoting violence.
That's documented thing is a huge issue.
Yeah,
that's,
that's not,
that's specified specifically targeting
individuals that and that thing is
Berkeley is like,
we can't stand for that.
That's not about free speech.
That's about safety and I feel like
that's where the word is hate speech
began.
Where does free speech begin?
Where it's a huge market area that even
the law can't tell you where it is and
so,
but those issues of what is free speech
and what isn't free speech or freedom of
expression,
you know,
again,
in the bay area I live right next to
Oakland.
Black Panthers were in Oakland,
California used to be an open carry
state until the black panthers like,
oh it is.
They went to Sacramento when Reagan was
there and like openly caring and people
were like,
Hey,
this open carries not such a good idea.
It's not really a debate right now.
In charlottesville though,
isn't letting it slide.
So it's about who's in power and what
they wanted to let you get away with
Charlottesville.
Open carry men.
Yeah.
Must Be.
There's no way.
There's no,
no,
there's definitely that.
I mean they,
you know,
that they,
I think they picked Charlottesville for
reason.
Isn't that weird though,
that there's,
it's like a liberal college will of
liberal art.
Liberal Arts college doesn't mean it's
liberal college with a Liberal Arts
College,
a blue.in the middle of this red state
that has open carry.
So like there's reasons they're
targeting these places.
I think Berkeley up until recently set
for like a soft target because they'd
been there twice and whooped our assets.
We're like all we can just catch the
third fight.
Mayweather,
Mcgregor,
fight in the octagon on arturo might
take it,
right?
Yeah.
So this third time it was like we were
like,
no,
we'll Charlottesville to me was so
representative of the Times that we're
in because all these white guys with
citronella candles they got from home
depot.
It's like,
why in the fuck?
Why don't you guys carry whole foods as
well?
Walk around with crocs on Tiki torches
are not white inventions.
So it's like a whole.
Like it's just the whole thing.
Like you had to,
you couldn't even bring your own.
You can just bring sticks.
You had to ring Polynesian Tiki torches.
But the whole torch thing,
like what the fuck are we doing?
Why do you have torches?
They're invoking the images of,
of white people carrying torches that
have terrorized people of color and
black.
But that's what it is.
That's exactly.
There's no other reason torch,
the free speech thing is like you're
purposely invoking an image because you
know you could've just held your phones
up with the lights on if you want to
head.
We were talking about those headlamps
you get when you go camping in the
woods.
Those are way better than those stupid
fucking torture,
but they want to look supreme.
That doesn't make you look supreme.
What torches represented.
Fire and fire is very volatile.
You could use that fire.
You could light things on fire like
we're at step one.
Step two is we start lighting shit on
fire with this fire.
Yeah,
like right now we're carrying it around
in a controlled manner,
but you're showing it in a way like a
step below open carry.
You're walking around with something
that you can use a light things on fire
and they know the history of white
people carrying torches as the clan,
so they're very purposefully doing the
thing.
I love the idea that like there's
probably a clan members like dudes.
That's where we wore the hoods so we
couldn't.
We didn't want to be fired.
That's why we wear the Hoodie,
getting fired left and Ryan cold out and
crying,
but I think they know that they know the
history of the fact that like if we show
up carrying torches,
it means something different than if we
show up wearing headlamps are carrying
our phone,
couldn't even get those fucking
Frankenstein style torches where they
raspberry too quickly,
so not real.
They had to replenish those every 15
minutes on movie sets.
Yeah,
they,
those as I learned what the clan that
would burn too quickly.
Yeah.
Well that's also the thing with flaming
arrows,
like people to think that you could like
light an Arrow and they go out and shoot
a fucking out wind and air works and
hundreds of feet per second.
You're shooting it through the air and
it's going to go out.
It's not going to be able to like that
boat on fire.
Get the fuck out.
You know,
there was probably,
there was probably a rehearsal for the
torch thing where they actually did have
regular torches and they're like,
oh,
this isn't working guys.
You know,
Home Depot is probably like,
wait,
how many fucking poses?
The biggest backyard?
What are you doing it at?
Home depot managers now,
like how many torches do they slow down
a second backyard torches.
Like what?
Those things with the like the bamboo
stalks that they're using for the bottom
or whatever the fuck the stick is.
It's just God.
It's so.
It's so the sign of the Times.
It's such a poser move.
Yep.
It is opposed to moving and yet they
know that if you're a black person
walking through the teachers through the
streets of Charlottesville and you see
that coming your way and you know you're
thinking,
you're invoked by images,
images of America's past where that was
like that equal death because they
weren't back then.
The tortures were for your house,
you know the torches were for you.
They were not for.
They were not just showing strength and
so and they know that and that's why
when people go,
it's just free speech.
It's like we have to stop acting like
that's just for your speech.
If you're walking around the torch,
it's definitely more than that.
You don't have to have a torch.
Everyone could see you.
It's not done.
It's not so dark out that we can't see
you.
Especially in those.
In that way.
My wife actually the other day was like,
there's a guy walking the street with a
blowtorch that she.
It's only now because we think like
what's that mean?
But like in the baby's a welder there.
Yeah,
exactly.
She wasn't,
she didn't call the cops.
She was just like on the phone.
He got organized through the torch,
but the idea is that that,
that didn't alert her because it was
just some guy walking around the torch,
but it's specifically the context of
nighttime.
A group of hundreds of white guys
carrying torches.
Walking towards people is like,
that's not,
that's not free speech.
That's not freedom of expression.
That chance,
this chance that they were yelling out
to the whole thing was just so fucking
bizarre.
It's like,
how did they organize?
Like where are these guys meeting up to
figure this out?
I feel like it's the.
It's the same thing as like live action
role play.
It's like they're meeting up online and
then they probably meet for the first
time when they get there,
you know,
and,
and I think it's also just really,
you know,
it's really,
it's really indicative of,
like you said,
the times we live in that they think
they can get away with this and then get
surprised when they get fired.
Like they think that like,
oh,
we'll just do that and then we'll go to
applebee's.
You
know,
dude,
we can see you.
So decretive of them being fucking
stupid,
which is why they're doing it in the
first place.
Which is why when the president goes on
both sides,
maybe there were people,
a lot of people said this,
maybe there were some white people are
like,
yeah,
I do feel like that my rights are being
a little bit trampled on and I really
want to show up the minute you hear
people chanting like all whatever the
antisemitic sematic things they were
saying.
You kind of go home.
Yeah.
Well what were they saying about take it
back from the Jews are stop the Jews
from taking over.
Yeah.
And then the president go,
yeah,
and the president can't come out against
that.
Well,
you know,
well he's seeing people open carrying
with military outfits on walking with
these folks.
He's seen these people walking down the
street with torches and he doesn't have
some sort of an articulate response to
that where he's saying,
look,
ladies and gents,
this is not being inclusive.
This is not.
This is not like stepping up and saying
that what we need to do is come to some
sort of an understanding and be at peace
with each other,
which is what America should be.
But will you.
Yeah.
But you started it wrong.
Articulate response.
Like that's not,
that's not his thing.
I mean he used to be more articulate,
which is really weird.
I don't think men should do anything
when they're 70.
I really don't.
I think they're older.
It doesn't work anymore.
They're fucking skin's falling off their
face.
Their back starts to hurt.
They're cranky.
I just think when you get to be that
age,
you should just shut the fuck up.
Yeah,
you should.
You should sit down.
You should go fishing or something.
Yeah.
But you definitely shouldn't have the
kind of insane high pressure job that by
the way,
nobody should have.
Nobody should be the one guy that run or
the one woman who runs the whole
country.
It's.
It's an insane responsibility.
I was reading about Obama.
Oh,
I put a tweet up yesterday about when
the Republicans were freaking out
because Obama wore a tan suit.
Yeah.
That there's all these this day and
Obama scandal,
like in the middle of a trump
that.
Yeah,
he could get you like,
oh my God.
They were.
They were trying to find something to
get mad at.
He was gay.
There'll be days when you wouldn't wear
a jacket.
Like he would just wear like a button
down shirt and a tie and people were
like,
you need to like bushes.
Thing was he always wore.
W Bush always wore a full suit and Obama
was like,
I'm still the president.
It's just hot in this room.
And people would gaze things that they
nit picked.
And this is the thing that's so stupid.
There's many people on the left who had
big,
huge disagreements with Obama that we
weren't able to express effectively
because we were too busy defending his
birth certificate.
It was a trump thing.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and that was the trump thing.
He was ahead of that shit was the head.
He was certainly.
He saw that thing happened in sort of
stepped into it like,
yeah,
like this spot.
Yeah.
We hire people to go investigate it and
Joe Arpaio was a part of this.
He sent people to.
There's all these tweets and he's like,
I just sent a team to Hawaii.
The things they found,
it's big.
It's sad.
It's amazing.
And then you look here we sit like
nobody ever held him in.
Trump never got held into account for
anything and still doesn't really get
held to account for anything that he
said or done.
What bothered you about Obama when he
was an office?
A lot of the stuff he did was business
as usual.
President stuff like,
you know,
using the military and nations and
killing innocent civilians that,
you know,
that didn't need to be caught up in a
war.
You know what I mean,
like drone shit and like,
you know,
I think,
we were supposed to get out of
Afghanistan.
It's just regular president shit that we
see that his first,
you know,
I,
I drank all the Obama Koolaid the first
time around,
you know,
hope and change a lot of hope and change
was about not being a president as
usual.
Also,
I don't think he really,
you know,
the thing that trump does really
effectively the thing that George w dot
Bush did really effectively.
Republicans do a good job of that.
They really know how to use the bully
pulpit to really push their things
through.
Not that trump has really done anything
to push things through,
but he knows how to be a bully from the
pulpit.
He hasn't really passing major
legislation but Obama because he was,
he wanted to be an adult and he really
wanted to be a unifier and I think a lot
of that comes really literally from the
fact that he's half black and half
white,
that he,
he has existed in more than one world.
He didn't.
I felt like there was times where it's
like to just say you are an effective
speaker,
you could really push through like
single payer health care in a way like
at least the debate on it,
you know,
so we don't settle for obamacare.
You know?
I think that there's,
I think that he didn't and I,
you know,
I've never talked to the man.
I've never met him.
I feel like I'm the only black person
associate with Hollywood has never met
Obama but piss you off.
No,
I just feel sort of like,
oh,
like I don't have.
My Dad has a picture of Obama.
I don't have been nice to be able to
tell my kids what was the first black
president.
Like I have no fucking idea.
Uh,
that he didn't,
that he didn't use the full force of
his,
of his presence because he was a
rockstar and I feel like that that could
have pushed some things through or at
least got us to debate things that even
Obama going to,
when they asked him about marriage,
gay marriage,
he was like,
I've evolved on that.
He had nothing to do with legalizing
marriage equality,
but the president saying that made a lot
of people go,
Huh,
maybe I'm ready to evolve.
You know what I mean?
I don't think he used the full force of
his,
of his bully pulpit in the way that I.
I always thought I wanted
him to drive the presidency of the way
the George W Bush did.
Like I.
There's no rules.
There's no law.
Do you feel like when someone gets into
office they realized how complex the
inner workings of the federal government
really are and then they just kind of
abandoned a lot of the ideas that they
wanted to push when they got in there.
I can remember when Obama had that hope
and change website that had all the
stuff about whistleblowers,
whistleblowers are going to be protected
under the Obama administration and then
as soon as you got an office,
he was worse on whistleblowers and
anybody.
And then he removed that section of the
hope and change website.
They deleted it after the whole,
you know,
the Edward Snowden thing and the Bradley
Manning thing,
Chelsea manning thing.
They were like,
fuck this,
you can't do that.
Yeah,
I do.
I think usually we're not seeing that
with this current president,
but I do think that's the thing where
they get in there and suddenly people
go,
you're [inaudible].
There's a part of this.
You are the most powerful individually
in the world,
but also the train is going this way
like it's already.
It's already left the station,
so you.
I do think that there is.
You're not going to get really an
ultimate revolutionary mindset in that
in the president's seat.
You just want somebody who's real,
who's reasonable.
You know what I mean?
You're not gonna.
Get somebody who's
the Elisa Garza from black lives matter
is not going to be the president as much
as I think she'd be great at it because
it's just not going to end up with
somebody who actually has a
revolutionary mindset,
so I think that.
And then so then if you start out there,
then when we put those people in there,
then they know,
I don't know what the pressures of the
officer.
I'm sure they're amazing,
but it automatically leads you to
capitulate and if you have a read of the
revolutionary mindset,
you mean you might be able to use that
for one aspect of being the leader of
the entire free world.
But what about all the other shit that
guy has to deal with all day long?
There's not enough time in the day.
No one has enough.
Trump apparently has enough time to go
golfing,
you know,
not doing it.
He's not doing this stuff.
How many people aren't even appointed in
the Pentagon shitload of jobs that they
haven't even filled yet?
Currently for trump.
There's extra time in the day,
you know,
but I do think and when I want to be
clear because you know,
because I know were listening.
When I say revolutionary mindset,
I mean single payer healthcare is a
revolutionary mindset.
Like every American has the right to,
to healthcare.
Every American has,
every American has the right to send
their kids to good public schools that
are well funded,
you know,
these are things I think that are like.
Or when I say revolutionary mindset,
I don't mean like setting things on
fire,
I mean like revolutionary ideas that
every person in this country deserves,
you know,
so now they think that that's,
those people aren't going to be in the
driver's seat of the White House.
Well,
utilizing the resources that we have
because of the fact that we pay taxes,
a tremendous amount of money goes to the
federal government with very little
recourse.
There's not,
there's no audit.
You don't get like some sort of.
It tells you exactly where your tax
dollars went.
You don't get to pick you,
please send this to the school.
Well yeah.
What would be important?
You know,
what would it be more important to fund?
I mean,
I think we should all have that
conversation and I just think that the
way it's structured right now,
the amount of power that corporations
have,
the amount of power that special
interest groups have influenced the
president.
The amount of just sheer money in
politics with lobbyists.
And you know,
there's this one community
outside of Washington DC.
It's one of the richest communities in
the world and it's all lobbyists.
Yeah.
I mean these are just people that using
and selling influence.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
I'm not.
People sort of call me a communist,
but I think I'm not a communist at all,
but I certainly don't get anything out
of capitalists.
I'm trying to make money.
I also believe I can help put a spread,
a better message and help you know and,
and use my resources to help people.
But I'm,
I'm in the,
I'm in show business like a business
show business.
Exactly.
I'm not,
I'm not.
I know activists and I know how hard
they work and then I sometimes use my
resources to help those people out and
donate money,
but I'm not like I'm not,
I'm in show business.
I'm trying to,
you know,
I,
I'm,
I'm in Kevin Hart's career,
you know what I mean?
Like I'm not Kevin Hart and I have a lot
of respect for Kevin Hart.
I think he's amazing,
but it's like I have to sort of remind
myself and other people like,
yeah,
I'm not of the people with the word
activist next to my name.
I'm like,
activist is actually a job.
I don't have that job.
I mean I do,
I do things that are engaged in
activism,
but I haven't met my tax form states,
the comedian,
you know,
what you have interests.
I'm interested in.
You also have thoughts about how things
can be better and you use your platform
to spread those thoughts.
Yeah.
And I also want a bigger house.
I get just like,
you know,
so and I think that like it's okay to
do,
to do all those things you,
you know,
as for my family,
not just because I want to roll around
my money.
I want a bigger house with my so I can
move my mom out to.
There are selfish interest interest in
there,
but uh,
you know,
so yeah,
not trying to,
not trying,
but I do think that this country has
level of resort.
Like there's a website,
it's called donorschoose.org and I'm not
trying to do a commercial,
but it just,
it's a website where schools in your
area,
you go to the website and you put in
your zip code and you will see the
school,
the public schools in your area that
need things and it's,
it's sad what they need.
We need paper,
right?
We need to like,
we're trying to teach the kids how to
like learn how to read and we don't have
any books.
Where the fuck did that happen?
Where did it go wrong?
There's so little money for schools that
teachers get paid like $30,000 a year
and it's supposed to survive off of that
and every teacher,
even at public and private schools,
but certainly public schools put their
paycheck back into the school because
they go,
the kids need a.
we're trying to teach,
you know,
a learning thing.
We don't have the stuff and they can't
afford it.
So every teach,
every public school teacher I've ever
known use some of their check to go back
into the school.
Yeah,
I mean it's just like he's one of the
most important things that we have there
not being entertaining,
making.
Yeah,
they're not making,
they're making $30 and some of them are
making $30,000 a year.
Some of them are like teacher's aides
who just out of college,
but they have to,
if they don't put money into the
classroom,
their kids will not have things and
that's not even private school teachers
do that but they may not put as much.
But yet every,
every teacher I've ever known has to do
that and we don't and we don't think
that's a problem.
Like I feel like why isn't it that I
feel like there'd be some way,
like why isn't Mark Zuckerberg public
school teacher getting a percentage?
Like,
you know what I mean,
like some sort of like just put,
there shouldn't be some tax on all of
us.
That goes back to our public school
teachers if we were to vote with school.
But I feel like it's weird to me that
like we're acting like these people come
to nowhere because Joel Olsteen's got
all that shit piled up basketball
stadium.
I do think there,
there nobody talks about that is like
hoarding money.
That's,
that's hoarding,
hoarding to pay taxes,
don't have to pay taxes.
You're fucking straight up hard and
yeah,
there's no,
there's no cat skeletons in there.
But that's an egg like billionaire
hoarding.
I feel like that's a thing,
you know what I mean?
That is literally what made the guy who
created scientology get involved in it.
And that's,
that was literally the idea behind l Ron
Hubbard making a shitload of money.
Created a religion.
Best way to make money.
Yeah.
It's literally his quote.
And then,
you know,
we talked to,
we were talking before we got on,
but there's all these like,
you know,
there's like religion is a good way to
make money,
but then there's all these motivational
speaker type where it's like,
I'm like looking like,
what are you,
where were you before you were this.
Exactly.
If Oprah's a motivational speaker.
Yeah,
motivate me.
What did you do?
But lies people.
I'm like,
there's some people like,
weren't you just a comic before?
Yeah,
not even a good one.
I know one of those.
I just feel like there's.
I didn't ask.
I know a guy was a hack.
He's a motivational speaker and you
listened to things you're like,
yeah,
that all sounds right,
but who are you?
I don't,
you know,
w w what?
What's your resume that you get to tell
this?
I mean all this stuff.
It sounded right.
We can all read fortune,
cookies,
actual achievement.
What's your.
Yeah.
What's your yet?
What,
what puts you.
I mean if,
if you,
for example,
were like this weekend and they'll era
in Berkeley.
I'm doing the Joe Rogan motivational
speaking training seminar.
I'd be like,
oh,
it goes what joe was talking about
because there's clearly a thing you've
done and you have done a lot of and you
could be like,
I want to know how this all happened.
You know,
how do I get my own podcast studio?
But there's a lot of people out there
who are sort of not.
They can't be a religious leader because
that,
that does require some work and you've
got to develop a new take on Jesus,
which is uh,
but uh,
but they're doing this thing where it's
like they're just,
they just are motivating people based on
the fact that they've read motivational
books.
The new take on Jesus is what Bieber's
guys doing right?
Is that I keep hearing wisps of beavers
that was happening is he has some Jesus
guy who's also influential athletes who
was the athletes he's got.
Oh
yeah,
well he's some up and come and Jesus,
a new take on Jesus apparently just
really knows how to sell it.
He just had a tickle.
Those balls of Jesus lovers slow because
I think it,
you know,
you get to that deeper level.
He's been famous since he was what,
12 and all the money and he's probably
had all the sex with every different
combination of humanity he went out with
and they,
this huge
next level.
He's got stem cell people working on new
and it's always at all that he's done.
All the substances you can do and all
the combinations.
And he's,
he's had all,
he's had all the new houses,
all the cars,
and then you wake up in a room like what
does this mean?
And so it's like,
I got a new take on Jesus for you.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You got wonder man,
why you gotta pull out earlier.
That's why you got to like as far as if
you.
Once you get to that,
let it be bird retired five years ago.
Is this the guy?
Oh Jesus.
Oh,
oh,
that is a new take this guy on my
podcast.
Three hours.
But you could find out what the fuck
that dude's.
Yeah,
that's.
That isn't new.
Take a look at that.
What?
The haircut and everything.
Like the Jesus beard.
But Jesus with the hipster haircut.
Yeah.
He looks like a band member.
Yeah,
it looks like.
Yeah.
Like he's like,
I could see him with a neck tattoo.
Yeah.
See,
this is like grungy Jesus,
because he's not like pastors don't
normally wear suits and stuff,
but yeah.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Your take on Jesus.
I don't think that anybody can get
through with bieber did and be any
better than he is.
I think it's insane to think that you
could take a child and not have them go
through the normal developmental shit
that we all go through.
Not being liked and trying to get people
to like you and dating a girl and being,
getting your heart broken,
you know,
getting in a fight and get in arguments
and not having any money in your
neighbor's houses and getting a fucking
yet neighbors mansion.
I mean he did a lot of fucked up shit,
but I mean he,
he is essentially like living on his
adolescent with a billion dollars in
public.
It's insane.
And I mean we already saw how that works
out with Michael Jackson.
Like it doesn't,
it doesn't,
it doesn't.
It doesn't go well for anybody who has
ever got through maybe Jodie Foster,
but I don't know her.
But yeah,
it might be the only ones.
I think she got through it,
but she also likes turned the volume way
down,
like just disappeared.
She moved to Paris.
She lived her life.
She had a whole family that people are
like,
I think she's
so,
yeah,
she,
you know,
it's like Kurt Russell's and other dude
who like was a huge movie star as a kid
and now it's just like,
you know,
not.
But most people don't get through that.
We can see the entire cast of different
strokes is gone.
Maybe not taught brutacos fucked up like
that.
You know who that's not,
uh,
that's not,
you know,
I have a,
my daughter,
I have two daughters,
but my oldest daughter is definitely a
performer and wants to be in stuff.
And I told my,
my agent yesterday,
if you ever see me bring her in here,
like I think I'm like,
that means that means we're done.
Yeah.
That means that I've lost all
perspective because I mean,
I don't think you're even a person until
you're 25.
You're a work in progress.
Why they don't let you rent a car and do
we need a person behind the wheel of
this?
By the way,
I didn't have that opinion until maybe
about five or six years ago.
I'm like slowly starting to develop
that.
Like realizing that when you see someone
who's young and stupid and doing dumb
shit,
like,
oh,
they're fucking brains not even ready
yet.
Yeah,
I read it.
I think.
Well,
the older you get,
you might keep raising that level two.
He might.
He might end up being 30 and
that that age bias.
You know what?
I think it's probably 68.
I think it's an age bias.
I think it's just understanding who you
are now today is very different than who
you were a decade ago or two decades.
If you're not,
you fucked up.
That's,
I think that's a Mohammed Ali quote,
a man who thinks the same way as 50
as he did it.
Thirty years wasted 20 years of his
life.
You know,
you should be going through some new
experiences.
She'd be wiser.
Wiser.
Yeah.
And you should be like,
man,
I can't believe I did that stump shit.
Yeah.
It's really sad when you talk to someone
who's 50 who doesn't know anything about
the world,
doesn't read,
doesn't pay attention.
It's so awful about trump is he seems
completely uncurious.
Like he doesn't seem like a curious
individual.
He doesn't seem like,
to me that's the worst,
that's worse than dumb.
That's worse than racist.
Like I feel like it's just completely
uncurious about the outside world.
Well also the way he like adorns his
homes with gold,
like a 12 year old just got like a magic
bottle.
He gets to rub,
rub this genie bottle and they're like,
what do I want?
I want everything
to furniture chandelier and if it's not
touchable gold,
gold colored,
you know,
like,
you know the people because the White
House,
this people work at the White House
forever.
No matter who the president is,
you know those people.
And they're like,
Oh God,
he's redecorating everything.
What is he doing?
Is that what he's doing in the White
House?
There's a whole renovation that's
happening.
Like that's why part of the reason they
said he went on his 17 daybreak is that
they were doing a bunch of renovations
in the White House,
allowed to just do whatever he wants.
He can do whatever you want.
So what if you wanted to do like
blacklight paintings that Jimi Hendrix,
Bruce Lee,
that's the problem with the,
with the presidency here to for.
We thought there was limits on stuff and
trump doesn't believe in limits.
So he was reserved.
We thought,
oh,
it'll naturally the natural selection of
running for president only elevates the
best people or the people most prepared
for the job.
And I mean I'm not obviously there's
lots of people get appointed to go to
that person,
but we generally.
People thought that like just the
natural selection process.
Like in the same way that like kinda
like connor just kind of mcgregor just
upset the whole thing.
Usually we thought up until then you had
to be a professional boxer who had lots
of fights before you got the floyd
mayweather.
And then caught is like,
I don't think that's the way that works.
And I'm not mad.
This is not about completely different
situation,
but I.
This is not about me.
I think I'm kind of a big car fan so I'm
not A.
I'm not mad,
but I know you're writing a new way.
The new way.
The people are like,
I didn't know you could do that and then
it makes other people get,
so I think trump has done that to the
presidency where it's like we thought
there was a,
just the process of natural selection
ended up with somebody who at least have
a through line of an idea because if you
don't agree with Bush,
George W Bush or you don't agree with
Clinton,
you at least knew there was a through
line of an idea and I think with trump
there's not the belief that there's a
through line of an idea.
Yeah.
And there's also this idea that he wings
things.
Yes.
He gets in,
has these press conferences,
like that one that he had that was
really set a lot of people back like
just a couple of months into his
presidency.
We went on this like 70 minute rant and
just rallied about fake news and people
came out of that going,
what in the fuck was that like?
Was that or not?
That was.
Was that the recent one?
Yeah,
no,
I'm talking like way earlier.
One of the first ones that he did.
I remember I got texts from friends who
are Republicans were like,
this is not good.
It seems unstable.
Yeah.
No,
and I think that,
I mean,
I think the one in Phoenix felt a little
bit like,
you know,
it's a little bit like Jeff Foxworthy do
in the old.
You might be a redneck joke.
He's like,
dude,
write some new stuff.
Like if he was still doing the same
stuff,
like he's still going over the same.
He still legislate.
He's like,
Dude,
stop saying Crooked Hillary.
We have as a nation,
even fans of Hillary,
like we got it.
Move on.
He's still doing the same electoral
victory and all these things that he's
been doing.
It doesn't seem like get to a new idea
man.
Well that was one of the really sad
moments when he was confronted by a
reporter and he was talking about how he
won by the biggest margin ever.
And the reporter said,
well actually sir,
that's not true because of this and that
now.
And he goes,
well,
I'm from Republicans as a Republican.
It's like,
no,
that's not true know.
And he starts rattling off the the
actual statistics and he goes,
well,
you'll agree that I won by a large
margin.
Right?
He goes,
you are the president.
It's like,
what?
Who are you like?
What kind of crazy ego battles at the
have on live television?
This is a guy who's way more related to
beaver than he is to any other president
as far as like,
he's surrounded by people who have told
him.
Good,
good job,
good decision.
I mean the.
There's a,
the insanity of like,
first of all,
there was the fake Time magazine cover
that was in one that was in his golf
courses.
I mean,
that's,
that's insane.
That's not,
that's just.
I mean,
we've all taken the fun fake magazine
cover.
We don't put it up and make people think
it's real.
You know what I mean?
Then there's another one that they just.
I just found out recently at one of his
golf courses,
there is a fake confederate monument.
There's a plaque that says there was a
battle here that was,
they called this the river of blood,
the Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
And they talk to historians like none of
that.
None of that happened.
It's at it's.
And it's got.
Donald says,
Donald Trump under the bottom,
like he saying,
Donald J dot trump.
This is what I.
This is what happened here.
And it,
none of it.
None of not.
It's not like,
oh,
it's an exaggerated dawn comes golf
course,
plaque honors,
fake civil war battle.
Holy Shit.
The river of blood people are like,
that's not.
This was never holy shit.
That is insane to me.
That's like the Potomac river near the
15th.
Green is shown during round three of the
senior Pga Championship at trump
national golf course on May 27th bob up
up above 2015 report about a factually
inaccurate,
inaccurate plaque featured at donald
trump's northern Virginia.
Trump national golf club has resurfaced
this week in light to the president's
controversial remarks about the violent
weekend in Charlottesville.
Fucking a man.
And they went to like three different
historians and one.
And they were like,
yeah,
that's.
There's no.
He's not even getting something wrong.
It's not like she had.
There was just.
Yeah,
just that didn't,
do you think he did that or someone did
that to him in the New York Times story?
They questioned him about it and he
says,
he says no.
I talked to his story and you said it
was a very bubbly blah,
blah,
blah.
He's,
he is in the a c?
No,
no.
Uh,
no way.
Nothing like that ever happened there,
which was the last segment about the
accuracy of the plaque,
however,
and told the publication that he was
certain that the area was a prime site
for river crossing.
So if people are crossing the river and
you happen to be
in a civil war,
I would say that people were shot a lot
of them.
What?
Because you understand how water goes
because you're in war.
When you're walking around was like you
don't get shot everywhere you are
because you're in war is the battle's
not everywhere.
People are the trump self-professed big
history fan was unable to name the
historians.
He claimed that told him the site was
known as the river of blood.
Oh,
this is so wow.
To me.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
and that's been there for a while,
so to me it's like,
this is again,
this is where the press,
forget the fake news media,
the fake,
the fake news.
This is where the press really fucked up
is by entertaining him through the
election season without really making it
hard effort to go right at the truth of
the matter.
Like people thought again,
I think people were still decided to,
well it's,
he's not going to win so we can drain
getting.
We're getting good at it.
Well,
I mean even people who didn't agree with
them,
people on the left,
you were like,
he's not going to win.
I had friends who were like,
I don't even waste time thinking about
it.
Yeah,
like you better realized,
probably want to waste some time that
they,
that they didn't.
People didn't go after him.
Hard to,
but all these little things.
Meanwhile,
let's again,
Obama had to pull out several copies of
his birth certificate
and yet people want to go.
I don't know if he's racist.
Trump,
I don't know.
Here's my take on it.
I don't give a fuck if he was born in
Kenya.
I don't care.
I don't remember where I was born.
They told me I was born in New Jersey,
but I wasn't there.
You were there but you weren't.
You weren't paying attention was
apparently I didn't understand words
like I didn't understand cities.
It's not your choice were to be born.
The idea that you're better off because
your choice was you.
Some by divine birthright.
You were shit out in Michigan so you
could run this country.
That's why the whole immigration thing
and the refugee thing is ridiculous,
but that's.
But it doesn't it.
It shouldn't matter,
but it does matter.
And also they were using.
He was born in Kenya as a way to promote
a lot of conspiracy theories that were
connected to him that would none of
that.
If you start to buy the.
Oh,
he was.
It was a fake birth certificate because
his parents,
when he was born knew he was going to be
the first black president,
so they got them a fake Hawaii and then
you attach a lot of things to him that
illegitimized his presidency because if
trump had said,
I don't agree with Obama's policy on
this and this and this and left all of
stuff behind,
then yeah,
let's see.
The run for president,
it was the craziest one was that he was
some sort of a mentoring candidate,
some sort of a,
a undercover Muslim that was sent to
destroy America.
He's trying to destroy America.
Can't he just be a disappointing
president?
Isn't that enough?
Must must we take it to that.
That's the part about this disturbing is
that Obama who was just.
They were questioning the legitimacy of
his presidency,
like just the fact that he shouldn't be
president [inaudible].
He's not.
He wasn't born here in this country and
he's a and then with trump,
all these things should be.
Should should question.
Is he fit enough to run for president?
Is He.
Is he a serious enough person?
Because I don't know,
you know,
he can you question people's mental,
but he's he a serious
enough person to run for president.
It's clearly.
No,
he's not serious enough to be president.
You have fake Time magazine Art Take
Time magazine one is almost inexcusable.
I mean it absolutely unexcused been on
the cover of time more than anybody
else,
which is again,
it's like this is not true.
But had he been on the cover before?
Actually,
but yeah,
but he had been.
He,
I think,
I think we'd have to look this up.
He had been on the cover but not that,
that picture it had.
It wasn't that picture.
It wasn't that.
There was do that then why wouldn't you
just frame the real one?
This is,
you have to ask you,
but that's what's crazy.
Right?
I mean the guy has actually been on time
magazine,
so if he has know,
but he's certainly been on the cover of
magazines.
I mean,
hey.
Yeah.
It's like get another one,
get one that you sound like you're not
famous.
So that's,
that's the weird part.
He needs to feel like the most famous.
He needs to feel like the.
What do you think?
What's the thought process behind that?
Did someone bring that to him?
Did he say,
I need to be on Time magazine?
If they don't put me on.
Kept me a fake one.
That's a real one.
No,
that's the big one.
That's the fake.
Because look,
Time magazine would never say trump is
hitting on all fronts.
Even TV.
It's entertainment weekly.
Obama's next move.
Can he curb healthcare costs?
How stressed at Chapin?
I don't.
That's weird.
The apprentice is a television smash.
Wow.
What?
I mean,
I feel it.
I feel like somebody made it for him as
a joke and then he is this real.
This one's real.
Okay.
What does it say?
There was this man may turn you green
within me or just turn you off?
Flaunting it is the game and trump is
the name.
That seems like a real one.
Yeah,
but it's also not complimentary enough.
Exactly.
He's not hitting on all fronts as trump.
Yeah.
How many people have looked at the
originals?
Like it's clearly not the right,
like the font isn't laid out.
There is all sorts of things that.
Yeah.
Well it looks fake.
It looks,
it looks like when you go to like the,
like a carnival and they give you like,
you know,
put you on the cover of sports
illustrated.
I don't like his lips.
There's something about.
It's like people like when they make
faces with their lips,
like you can kind of tell if they're
kind.
Yes.
It says,
it seems so weird to say that,
but it seems to be true.
Well,
yeah.
It's like he,
he does.
Again,
he does not angry.
He.
Yeah,
he looks,
he looks like he's perpetually either he
looks,
he looks disappointed when he sits
there.
It's the massive amount of money and
power and then deciding I want to run
the thing to really want to be.
That's the thing.
He didn't really want to be.
They don't personally know.
I think he,
yeah.
I don't think he could have anticipated
that he was running against 16 people or
15 people who just couldn't.
Who Know,
who should have all been the clear like,
you know,
any of them should have been like,
well,
money Jeb Bush he gives,
but they,
none of them had enough personality to
top him.
Bush seemed like you didn't really want
to do it either.
Seems like he was Kinda like half ass in
it.
Well,
I don't think George w really want to do
either.
That's the thing about America.
You can become the president and not
even really wanted.
If you're a rich white dude,
like I guess I'll
be the president.
Well who the fuck is going to do it
next?
That's what's going to be interesting.
I just hope it's not the people that.
Whose names I already know.
I hope it's not.
People talk about maybe Biden.
Can it not be so much?
Maybe I just feel like the thing about
that was excited about Obama.
The black thing was exciting for me
personally,
but the fact that he was under the age,
like he was in his forties,
that was exciting.
Like it was like a president who would
actually,
who you know had life,
had life and,
and also was still had a lot of life
ahead of him.
Like Dad did.
He,
now that he's done,
he's still like a young,
a young,
old man,
you know,
that he was,
that he had done things you had probably
done.
He was like,
yeah,
I did a little coke and
he probably played video games.
He understood,
you know,
he,
the reason why I became such a pop
culture president because it was like he
would say I listen to Jay z and you're
like,
I believe he probably does.
You know what I mean?
Like it just felt like he felt like
somebody who was connected to us in a
way that like trump is not,
he's not one of them.
That's the whole,
he's not one of the people and he's
never tried to be one of the.
People know.
It's all so strange.
I've never felt more disconnected than
right now from politics and from like,
I've never felt like the president is
more disconnected from the people in the
United States either.
And the people that support him,
boy there,
so I've never seen that before,
either the type of people that are like
really into Donald Trump being
president,
you know,
just everything.
And he says they hang on every word,
they turn everything into a positive,
they spin everything,
they hashtag Maga.
It's really awesome.
And it feels to me like it's a very much
a,
you got Obama,
we get him like it feels like it's very,
like,
like they were sick of how of the love
that Obama got even though by the end,
I mean Obama got a lot of love but it
wasn't as fervent by the end,
you know?
But I mean until the.
And then he got perfect right before he
left.
But it's a real sort of like,
a lot of that love of trump comes from.
It's real.
Like it's like wanting to spite
liberals.
Like,
you know,
ha ha ha.
Like you don't care if trump does
something that's bad for you.
If it hurts the liberals feelings,
you know,
like you,
you,
you just,
you just want somebody who is hurting
hillary,
you know what I mean?
Or hurting the liberal you're not.
It's not about what's good for you
because if you're looking at what's good
for you,
this is not good for you.
Yeah,
well it's also like getting some sort of
a reasonable conservative that would.
Someone would step up right now would be
very interesting.
It will be very interesting if you could
find someone who's a reasonable
conservative who knows how to debate and
conform a sentence and can respond under
pressure to like what trump also brings
to the table as he's like this ominous
sort of character.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's like a Mardi gras float that walked
into the.
There's a lot to deal with.
It's a lot to.
It's a lot to deal with.
Yeah,
and I think that the problem is,
is that,
you know,
there's all these people who are trying
to position themselves as the,
as the trump alternative,
but then if you dig too deep into their
records,
it's like,
well,
they really support all the things trump
supports,
but they're just not out loud racists.
So it's like,
it's not,
it's not really like an,
it's not an alternative.
It's like,
I think all,
I think both parties,
it's gotta be you gotta be looking for
New People.
Like I feel like I would say like in the
eighties it felt like the NBA just went
to Africa and grabbed tall people.
They're just like,
we need to find some new people and they
got the campaign,
but tombow and chemo,
Elijah won and it's just like they were
just like,
we need to go.
And I feel like if I'm the Democratic
Party,
I'm scouring the United States of
America for people who.
Nobody's EXP,
you know,
for like,
is there a city comptroller somewhere
who's got a good speaking voice?
Let's go get that.
Dude.
I feel like that's.
You can't be looking at the regular
halls of power.
Do you watch house of cards?
Ideally?
Do you wonder if that's how it really
goes down?
I want to know how accurate it is.
I want them was killed.
I want to know Clayton sensing to feel
like that,
that probably no,
uh,
no sen has pushed or representative is
push somebody into a subway train.
I have to sort of,
spoiler alert season one,
season two A.
Yeah,
I have to believe that,
but I do believe all the.
Yeah,
I think some of it is true.
Some of it's got.
Someone's got to be based in truth,
but the thing is I didn't watch this
season of house of cards because I was
like,
I,
it's,
I can't,
I can't.
I have to be focused on the real
hospital.
Like I couldn't.
I was watching it like this.
It didn't land in the same way,
but it's so good.
Okay.
I'll go back.
Can.
I just was like,
I was watching it thinking like watching
trump tweets.
Like I couldn't focus on that.
I'm like,
it's really bad over here guys.
I wonder how it's gonna play out.
Do you think he's gonna make it through
four years in the White House?
I think we have to.
Those of us who don't think he should
make it through four years in the White
House or hope that he resigns or gets
impeached,
can't take it for granted.
That's going to happen.
I don't think we can.
So is he gonna make it through four
years?
The history says yes,
most of them do.
You know,
there's,
you know,
there's not a point at which,
it's very the impeach thing.
And also the impeach thing doesn't
necessarily get you out of the office
and just,
you know.
So I think that a Clinton was impeached.
Yeah.
I forget.
No,
it's like it doesn't impeach.
Doesn't mean you're fired as much as
we'd like to believe it does.
So I think it's way.
If I'm in Vegas,
it's way more likely.
It's like the floyd mayweather,
Mcgregor odds.
It's like it's way more the bet.
The bet that he makes it through.
Yeah.
I don't think that there's.
Things are already off the rails,
so I don't think we can go.
Well,
clearly he's spooky.
Thing is a second term.
I think it's.
I think the reality is that after four
years I visited,
think if he does leslie for years that
he gets to the end of four years,
I
felt like this is really hurting.
It's also if it's because it's hurting
his business brands,
you know,
like he's like,
people are canceling hotel reservations
and like I think of the pcs is bottom
line going down instead of going up,
is it.
I mean I've,
I've,
I've heard that like a bunch of people
pulled out reservations from Mar Lago
and things like that.
So they take the name off of one of his
buildings in downtown New York.
That makes,
I mean I can you do that?
Is it a condo?
So I think they decided to take the name
off one of the war.
It does not say.
Yeah,
people weren't buying condos.
Didn't want to.
Yeah.
It's like that story made off business
management.
That's a good idea,
right?
Yeah.
But I do
think that like if it's effect really
[inaudible] like you know,
it certainly has.
There's reports that have like Ivanka is
brands are down,
you know,
like the thing are not.
They thought this is going to help that
stuff and if it's not helping that stuff
and at the end of four years and it's
Kinda,
I think he could leave because he's
annoyed by it all,
but he'll have some big speech about I
have done what I came to do and I think
I've really drained this.
We'll just say he did and his people
will be like,
Yay.
You know,
talk about how unemployment was at his
lowest rate in 15 years.
Even though the arc that unemployment is
on as the same like arc that it's been
on anime arcs,
let's all go to the same path that it
was always there.
It's always been on.
I think there was some initial
speculation that he was going to be good
for business and then there was some
sort of a rise and that is,
is that all.
It's important.
It's good for business trump name to be
removed from three Manhattan apartment
buildings.
He doesn't own.
Oh,
he doesn't own them.
Well,
I think he sells.
He sells his name a lot.
He people think he owns more than young.
Oh,
okay.
There've been owned by a Chicago based
real estate equity from a,
from Ra residential,
uh,
equity residential since 2005 now trump
place.
So they'll remain on the condominium
buildings 200 to 20 to 40 Riverside
Boulevard,
which neither equity,
residential nor trump on how weird for
now.
Yeah,
they're going to remove it though,
Huh?
Well,
a lot of it was he was selling his name
to stuff or licensed because name of
this stuff.
So it wasn't.
People thought he had more than he had,
which is why he doesn't show his tax
returns because it's like,
it's not as a it,
you know,
how weird is that?
Does he doesn't show his tax return.
The rules are different.
The rules are different for,
uh,
for,
for rich white men.
The rules are different.
But is that,
is that like a mandatory thing?
Because now it's obviously not,
it's not a legal thing,
it's just what has been done.
And the problem is again,
there may,
they may make it after trump that it's
illegal thing.
All these things were sort of like that
the president,
just what had been done.
And what people assumed would always be
done.
And then trump,
the one shining grace of trump is that
it proved it,
that it exposes how that stuff isn't.
That's we think there's more that it's
more complicated to become the president
and more complicated to be the president
and that there's more restraints on the
president than there actually are.
So now that we know that maybe,
but when trump leaves,
eventually I think it's forgetting
Republicans,
Democrats.
It's on the benefit of humanity for the
benefit for the entire world that the
president doesn't have the,
they can't launch nukes.
That's just,
I'm not making this a Republican,
a democrat.
It's just,
uh,
it,
it should be a couple more people than
just one guy.
Or what about pardoning people that are
criminals?
Like how again,
is that the case?
Like you have laws,
but then you have a president who
apparently can't be charged with laws or
can't be charged with crimes.
Right.
Which is why these women that were
trying to sue him,
they can't do anything about it now that
he's the president has that would happen
because I was like,
man,
he can't really do what I'm saying
because it gets in the way.
That's the way
the unemployment line is going up.
We can't really deal with women who say
you were harassed is.
Yeah.
I think that's what when these women
were trying to sue him when he was
running for president,
I think he got rid of all that shit.
Wow.
I did.
Was.
I was like,
I should google that,
but yeah,
that would happen.
Okay.
I mean,
can you pardon himself?
How does that work?
That's the thing.
People don't.
There's like this weird.
There's all this stuff that happens in
the law where they're like,
we've never actually asked that question
because nobody thought that was a
question that you'd be asked.
Like nobody ever thought that a
president would think to do that.
You know?
So there's all these sorts of things
where it's like there's no,
you know,
he would,
he could sign a thing and then the
supreme court would have to be like,
is this okay?
Is this okay?
You get a number of pardons too,
right?
Don't they get like 20 or something like
that?
No,
I don't think.
Yeah,
they,
I think they have a limited number
though.
I think there's a limited number of
senior.
All right.
You got 50 letters.
It's like you're playing a game.
All right.
Where do I go?
Where do I go with these pardons?
And now after he did a pile,
it's like the,
you know,
it's,
it's even mccain freaked out about our
pile canes from Arizona and he knows,
he knows our piles of criminal,
you know.
Now the question is why didn't you do
something about it before mccain?
Again,
you don't have any jurisdiction in that
way,
but you could have been used or bully
pulpit more effectively if you thought
he was a criminal before this,
you know,
Mccain's defense.
He had a brain tumor.
I don't mean now.
I mean I didn't even ago.
I don't know how many do Obama.
This is a list.
I'm just scrolling down.
It goes forever.
Hundreds.
Yeah.
And Obama didn't do the most.
I want to be clear but.
But yeah,
I think there.
Is there a limit?
Does it say how many confer limit?
This is justice dot Gov website.
I don't think there's a limit.
That's crazy.
He pardons are so weird.
Yeah,
I know you're a criminal,
but magic there is.
I mean the part of it that should be
good is there are many people who are in
prison again,
like we talked about earlier for things
where you like the rest of your life.
You know what I mean?
Like,
so there is a good side to this,
but we thought that they would only be.
A lot of times it's like friends and
colleagues and you know,
the way I would pardon people like
Bradley Manning,
Chelsea manning thing pardoned her.
Right.
That wasn't.
Yeah.
That was an example of you have served.
Obama was like you have served more than
enough time.
Yeah.
Two hundred and 12 people,
but that's not the most.
I think that's the.
Oh my God,
and,
and commuted the convictions of a
further 1,715 people hillbillies.
She had the thing where he went,
he actually went to federal prison and
talk to inmates and it was all
nonviolent people.
Again,
the same thing.
People who have been convicted of
nonviolent crimes who were just
languishing in prison for.
No,
you know,
he smoked a lot of weed and sold a lot
of weed.
But you've been here for 30 years,
you know.
Wow.
Yeah.
Most of,
uh,
most granted clemency by Obama had been
convicted on drug charges.
I never receive lengthy and sometimes
mandatory sentences at the height of the
war on drugs.
That's the scariest thing about that
jeff sessions asshole.
He wanted to bring that stuff back and
bring back.
Just say no and start arresting people
for pot.
Like,
come on man.
It's 2017.
We got to catch up.
Well,
yeah,
we got and we were about to catch up and
we were,
we were getting close.
That will now we're getting,
we're getting close.
But like,
because I feel like
even if you had a 45 year old republican
president,
they would be,
they would be more open to things than
the 71 year old trump,
you know,
are they are any 71 year old republican
or Democrat just by the nature of the
fact that like for the most part,
45 year old Republicans don't care about
where people go to the bathroom as long
as they,
you know,
old people shouldn't be running shit.
I used to,
I did this job briefly but it didn't,
I didn't stick.
But it was eddie like you can be too
young to vote and you can also be too
old to vote.
The idea.
Yeah.
That like there's a point at which
there's a part of life where you were in
the world doing things and you're in the
mix and there's a part where you're sort
of like,
you know,
where,
I think well at least we should.
We should do some checks first.
Like,
yeah,
for sure.
Can you do a cartwheel?
Yeah.
Can you?
Can you walk a straight line?
But I like how,
how well does your body doesn't.
It doesn't make sense that it would be
the oldest person to be the.
It doesn't make.
It doesn't make any sense.
It does.
If it's an incredibly wise old person
who's like learned a bunch of things and
has control of their ego and as a person
who really wants to make the world a
better place,
but it's also awesome hgh so they can
actually do this live up to the rigors
of the job.
You know what I mean?
Like,
well that was.
What did you read about Obama?
Not Obama,
about people thinking that trump's on
stimulants.
I couldn't remember where I saw it from
because when I looked back up,
like that said,
there is no real history of him using
drugs.
People.
I've had rumors that maybe he was doing
like phen phen and whatnot in the
eighties or something like that.
I don't.
I wonder where the guy gets the energy.
Like when he was,
when he was doing that whole thing with
Hillary and then it was revealed that a
hillary,
when they were running for president was
on new vigil or provigil,
which is,
um,
a narcolepsy drug say give it to a
fighter pilots to keep them awake.
I've taken it before.
It's interesting because she actually on
it.
Yeah,
for sure.
And a lot of people take that stuff.
And what it does is it kind of keeps you
awake and it keeps you alert.
Even if you start getting tired,
it keeps you from falling asleep,
but it doesn't change it from up.
Not,
not at a press conference or it doesn't
speed you up.
Which is interesting because it doesn't
like,
it's not like tweaking.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's not like a,
an amphetamine.
It's some weird thing.
Yeah.
It was essentially originally created as
a performance enhancing drug,
but they needed some sort of a,
a reason to medically prescribed it to
people.
So they want a narcolepsy.
Narcolepsy is found it.
Yeah.
What do you got here?
But is it legitimate?
Is actual truth.
But MSNBC,
fun fact.
In 1982,
trump started taking an amphetamine
derivatives,
abused them only supposed to take two
for 25 days.
Stayed on for eight years.
Really?
How the fuck does he know when you're
saying something like that,
man,
you gotta you gotTa have something other
than fun fact.
It's a tweet storm.
Is there something at the end where he's
got like a tweet storm?
I love that fucking fashion.
I just,
I just texted it to like,
what is happening to my life?
Look at.
Check out this tweet.
Storm.
Tweet,
storm,
Dr Joseph.
What does it say up there?
It said the doctor wrote the
prescriptions.
Dr Joseph Greenberg diagnosed him with
metabolic imbalance,
which we have never heard about again.
Greenberg was later publicly shamed
sham.
Oh,
slammed rather sorry.
As someone who provides uppers to rich
people in Manhattan and medical
metabolic imbalance of true could be a
or electrolyte info.
Insufficiencies anaerobic and balances,
acid imbalances and assortment of
related disorders that can have serious
health consequences.
Yet his other doctor,
Dr Harold Bernstein Bernstein said he
had been trump's dr since 1980 and never
mentioned the metabolic imbalance found
by Greenberg.
How's he know this though?
Like you have to Kinda like reading a
book and doing research.
So you've got to have.
I mean he's a,
he's a,
he's a legit journalist,
but I,
yes you do have to eat.
But he also certainly opening himself
with being sued if it's not true.
So you always kind of be sued if it is
true.
Right.
But that would make sense because if
you,
if you see like how much energy he had
when he was running,
doing the campaign against Hillary.
God Damn.
The guy never got tired.
Yeah.
And he would go up there to the White
House,
admitted it to me,
said only for a short time for diet when
he was not overweight.
I countered with Med records.
They cut me off people misreading drug
was di Etho got.
He's got the Duane Reed in Manhattan
where it was filled at seven milligrams
a day.
Prescription filled at Duane reed on
57th street in Manhattan.
Seventy 5 million other things?
Seventy five milligrams a day,
Huh?
Yeah.
I don't know what that is though.
But he's,
I mean he certainly is right in the
book.
He's apparently.
Yeah.
He's interesting.
He's certainly.
Well that would make sense.
That would make sense why he has this
kind of energy.
I know so many journalists that are on
adderall and I have a friend who told me
that they're all on it.
I mean,
I don't know what that means.
I mean 80 percent 60,
what does it mean?
But he's like,
listen man,
they're all on adderall.
And that was one of the things that when
I,
what is it?
What was his name?
That uh,
that guy that I'm crashed his car under
suspicious.
Suspicious.
Michael Hastings.
Remember that?
Crashed his car under suspicious
circumstances.
And they said,
oh,
well this guy had meth in his died yet
amphetamines in his blood.
He was probably fucked up on pills.
No,
he's probably a fucking journalist.
Yeah,
they're all on amphetamines.
Yeah.
And that's what adderall is,
a prescription amphetamine that you can
get if he's like,
man,
I've been kind of dragging ass lately
when
Dr says never had that doctor.
I've had the.
I've been dragging ass lately.
You should probably exercise and get
more arrests.
This motherfucker's real.
You're right.
But isn't there other things you could
do?
What I
needed to ask about these things,
bro.
I got back pain,
I'm always tired,
stressed,
suited my back pain and I want to float
through life with not a care in the
world so I can take care of my family
business.
Yeah,
I'm really stressed out.
You need to organize your day better
or that's not what I was looking for.
Like to talk to a therapist.
We got to get someone like Elon Musk.
We got to get like some super genius.
She seems to be able to do everything.
Well that's the thing.
The other sort of good side of this is
that it is certainly opened up the
possibilities of who can be the
president.
Like it is completely blown now will
some person who's not a Republican,
you know,
like step through like Lilla liberal
step through that will the Democratic
Party support that person because you
know,
you hear like the rocket might run for
president.
He was gonna probably do it while he's
working out on a
talking.
He live streaming has run for president.
Yeah,
I mean,
but,
but the Democratic Party might be like,
you know,
are they going to get behind that kind
of person?
You know,
they don't have a fucking choice.
This is a rock to rock decides to run
for president.
I'll fucking help them out of the
finding is people are like,
we don't even know that the rock is a
democrat.
You don't know what.
He's not a guy who has declared his
political affiliation.
That's true.
And he's a,
he's a,
he's a rich guy.
You know?
That's true too.
Yeah.
But he's so rich.
He probably doesn't even notice his
taxes.
That's what I mean.
The Moroccans hit that elite
stratosphere,
but like feel like $3,
million more for taxis.
Like you just thought,
fuck I gotta lift weights or you father
trying to get to my pump on over here
too.
Let's move on.
Less depressing shed because I want to
talk about some.
I want to talk about your show and what,
what,
what has this been like for you?
Because you know,
your show is a very unique show on CNN
and it seems like,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but it seems like you have a lot of
creative leeway.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I mean it seems like you.
Yes.
That's the thing about the show that has
been such a,
it's been so cool because,
you know,
I've had a career where I was like a
sort of in the trenches,
you know,
uh,
for a long time just trying to figure it
out and didn't think I'd ever get this
opportunity in the way that I got.
There was not some way that made any
sense.
But now I sit in a room.
I just had a kickoff meeting yesterday
and it's a room full of people,
like what do you want to do?
Come out and,
you know,
and it's like I feel super a Hashtag
blessed to be in that position
because it's like,
it was not something that five years ago
it wasn't like,
oh,
probably end up seeing it and also to be
at CNN that wasn't.
None of these things were on my,
like how did it happen?
Uh,
so after my show totally biased that
Chris had executive produced.
I was,
didn't have a job,
didn't know what I was going to do.
We in New York and that was on fx and fx
and fx x and then get the Fx Outta here.
So yeah,
it was on,
it was on Fx.
Now fx is legit channel,
but we might show helped launch fx and
didn't do a good job.
So that's why the show got canceled.
But uh,
so I'd started to take meetings,
like general meetings and I ended up at
a.
and it was always sort of news
organizations like little online,
like I found it wasn't like
entertainment channels.
It was all these news things that
thought like you could do something here
with your thing.
And nobody had a real idea and I went to
CNN and met Jeff Zucker had the like a
15 minute meeting with Jeff Zucker where
he was like,
had 18,000 tvs on and gave me a news
quiz.
He's like,
you pay attention to the news?
I go,
yeah.
And he gave me a news quiz to see if I
paid attention to the news.
Like he was like,
let's see,
I'm give you a quiz.
Like what did he ask you?
It was all the kind of shit that if you
have like at the scene in app on your
phone,
you would know all of it.
It's like it was really like he was just
the big news stories of the day.
Like it was like a.
do you know what whatsapp is?
WHATSAPP,
which just been bought by facebook.
I was like,
yeah.
So after it was bought by facebook,
like it was like a game show and it was
just like.
I mean it was funny,
but he just wanted to see.
I don't know,
people have,
don't have much respect for community.
I don't mean Jeff as,
as people who are paying attention all
the time.
I think he wanted to see if I was for
real and I was like,
yeah,
so and then so they didn't want to see
your mindset.
Well you know,
are you concentrating on being the next
Kevin Hart or Ashley,
do you have any actual interests?
Are you going to,
can you come into this new space and be
well,
can you,
because I'm seeing it and you can't.
You have to sort of be paying attention
to the news.
So can you pay attention to what's going
on here?
The bridge gate thing happening.
It's like,
what do you think Christie says,
you and I sort of riff some things out.
And he was like,
all right,
it's the same shit trumps on weight.
So He.
So then they had been pitched the show
by this company,
all three media now,
main event media called black man white
America where a black man travels around
to all to white spaces in America.
That was the premise and they told me
that and I was like,
bad,
don't want to do like,
you know,
like I wouldn't want to do that.
I would want to do it if I could travel
more than just white spaces.
And they liked that idea.
And then the Guy Jimmy Fox,
he hates when I tell the story because
he's like,
it was such,
he does.
He's like,
he realizes that it wasn't the best
idea,
but it was like,
so then we changed it.
He changed it to united shades of
America.
And then we pitched the Klan episode.
That was my idea to talk to the pilot
episode was me with the Klan.
What the fuck was that like?
I mean,
it was,
it's funny people ask me that.
I feel like it's exactly what you think
it was.
It was.
I mean,
you know,
it was a,
I like because it was different versions
of the clan.
The big one was where they went to the,
where I went to the cross burning what
they call a cross lighting.
A got to be politically correct.
Uh,
so it,
I mean we drove,
I drove into this place,
I had the camera crew,
there was one security guy.
There we go.
Uh,
that was the first day of my first day
at work on the United States of America.
That was the last thing we did that day.
The trailer?
Yeah,
no it was,
it was off in the woods and Kentucky and
that was my first day on the job.
This was the last thing we did was watch
across burn and we and also when we got
there we got there during daylight so we
had to be there for several,
like two or three hours while they did
all their rights while I talked to them
and interview them.
They did rites and rituals and then it
ended with them setting the crossword
and they were more than willing to do
all this on television,
which is even more shocked.
They mostly there,
you can see up there.
They mostly kept their hoods on,
but one guy kept,
took his hood off so you could see his
face.
But yeah,
they were all there.
I mean,
people ask me like,
why would they want to be on tv because
everybody wants to be on TV.
Like we talked to a bunch of different
clan groups and are they the producers?
Did,
most of them didn't want to be on tv,
but there was like three or four that
did because they were.
They thought they were spreading the
word.
Maybe they were,
you know,
what was their message like when you
were talking to them?
Like what?
What was the reason for doing this?
They believe America is a white country
ordained by God that way they believe
the Bible says that's true.
They believe the Bible talks about
America.
It's like I'm not telling you what I
believe,
but they believe that the Bible doesn't
think that the racist should mix.
The Bible doesn't,
you know,
all these things that people quite of
the Bible,
the Bible's talking about donkeys.
And they were like,
you know,
so the data.
And they believed that America is a
white country founded by white people.
And that,
that the,
that the people who like the black
people in the Mexican people and
eventually the Catholics and the Jews
only they can say cooler with Catholics
now that you state the Catholics should
get to leave,
go back home.
And because America is a and end,
the whole America is for white people is
the whole white is just a different way
of saying the white ethno state thing
that a lot of the people rather than
outright in the national white
nationalist movement say.
And so you know,
they,
they think that this is,
that they,
they think America's,
they think this whole idea of America is
that it's for whites only and that the
rest of us need to go home.
How does it feel for you?
I mean,
I'd be standing there with these people
in the woods in Kentucky looking into
the eyes of madness.
Why they're wearing satin sheets over
their head with holes poked out for
eyes,
sort of.
It was a lot of it.
That was fun.
I mean,
it was like we got there,
I got out of the car and there's a line
in the,
in the show where you can hear me before
you see that I'm going like,
oh,
this wasn't a good idea,
and that was really me saying this was
not a good idea.
That was not me making a joke because I
see a phalanx of them and they're all
standing there at attention and right
when we got there,
the guy who was an all blue was like
immediately goes into a rant about
Ferguson.
It was in 2014,
so it was all about Ferguson and how
black people and police themselves and
the white man is going to Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
While at the same time they don't
advocate violence because it's clear
that at some point they were told if you
talk about violence,
the FBI will be here every weekend,
you know,
so they're like,
we don't advocate violence.
We advocate self defense.
We don't hate black people.
We just love our people.
But also black people can't look what
they're doing in Ferguson that shows
that black people aren't whatever,
blah blah,
blah are the equivalent of the white
man.
And uh,
and so I had to.
So when we first started shooting,
there was just like,
this guy was just going off and I just
sorta was like having to take it and
wondering is this going to be the next
three hours of just like yelling?
And the producer stepped in and said,
all right,
everybody,
let's just,
Oh,
we got to check the camera for a second.
And we slowed it down.
And then we set up chairs.
When we sat down and started talking.
And from that point forward they were so
excited to talk about their clan thing
because they don't get asked that a lot
that they sort of like eventually you
would,
if you weren't thinking that it was the
Klan,
you'd be like,
yeah,
this is just people talking about their
lives.
I don't agree with them,
but they're not.
They didn't stay angry by the end they
were like,
oh brother,
get good sleep as a good time.
Man.
They,
they certainly hug it out.
No,
no.
I said to the,
I like,
do not take any pictures of me hanging
out.
Like,
cause I'm doing it as a way like,
yeah,
thanks man.
But you know,
try to reason with them.
Yeah,
no,
I talked to like,
because you know,
because you go,
well you know,
like there was one point they said the
Bible says that uh,
that,
you know,
managed not to Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
I was like,
you put the Bible also says you
shouldn't eat lobster,
you know,
what do you think?
Well I just went to red lobster last
night brother and you know,
so they recognize the hypocrisy but they
can't see why it doesn't make sense.
Like,
you know,
they,
they don't see why like,
well if you,
you're just saying these things,
these aren't,
the Bible should not be the reason this
is happening,
you know?
So it's just a convenient way to justify
wearing their goofy clothes.
Yeah.
And so they,
I mean they're,
they said they don't.
This was called the new clan.
They don't hate black people,
they just really love white people.
But I feel like you can really love
white people,
but it shouldn't come with at the
expense of black people feeling safe or
anybody feeling safe.
It's the same thing with the all right,
you can think what you want to think,
but nobody should feel like their safety
is being violated in that process.
So,
you know,
the funny thing was is that,
so we would film it and we'd have to
stop down because we were changing
cameras whenever we stopped and they
pull off the hoods off and they'd be
like,
man,
it's hot under here.
And I was like,
yeah,
maybe you guys should have designed the
hoods more breathable fabric.
Maybe get under armour in here.
But they didn't,
we didn't use it on camera because we
can show their faces.
But yeah.
So it was like they were like,
there were some,
there was like two different groups.
There was one group who like was okay
talking to me.
And then there was another group where
every time we stopped down,
they would go away.
They would walk away and one of them was
this blonde was the one who was in red
when she took her hood off.
She was like,
I mean she looked like the Brittany
spears at 18,
like this blonde,
you know,
as we sound earlier,
maybe I don't know what a pretty white
woman looks like.
She was,
but she was abroad.
She had red fingernails but,
and she was wearing a red,
a red thing because she's fourth
generation clan.
So her thing is all red and she looked
like,
because she's fourth generation,
she was ready.
You get to wear the blue
belt system.
I didn't get the whole fourth
generation.
So she.
But she's like,
so she like,
every time she took her hood off she
looked like she was like,
she wanted to kill me,
you know,
it never.
I never thought,
well yeah or that they had never,
never.
And I was like kind of a couple of
drinks.
Dinner.
You guys started dancing.
I just feel like if I could just take
you to la,
there's a whole life for you at away
from Kentucky where that you would have.
You know,
I can make a lot of money off your kid.
Isn't it so funny though that it's just
what you're exposed to.
If you're a young child and you just
don't understand your clan and your pr
and there's black people,
there's not enough black people in the
community for you to go.
Well that's weird because he's black
people are fine because in this part of
Kentucky there's not a lot of black
people.
There are,
there are some because that's black
people everywhere,
but there's not enough to like sort of
for these people to interact with and
you're told to avoid that black guy who
works at the home depot.
Then you ended up,
you know,
and you just see that it's like it's
about circumstance.
It's not necessarily about,
you know,
if we could get the.
If you get people out of these
circumstances,
I think they would change,
but I want to have the input of the
environment that you're in.
It just kits so people get so wrapped up
in,
caught up in it and it becomes how they
think and it's.
You don't want to stand out from the
group,
you don't want to be ostracized and
there's a fucking cross.
It's not gonna light itself was okay.
We're really excited.
Like this one guy I talked to,
we sort of built a rapport in that
moment and he was excited to talk about
how they were like,
where'd you get the wood from?
Why do you do like,
he was excited.
It was like,
you know,
it was like this old,
this old cross,
you know,
like he was
excited.
He was excited to talk about this stuff
and so we sort of talked on that level
and I still asked all the.
And I was like,
obviously I don't agree with you guys.
And I said it as like in a,
hopefully at the angel let me leave,
which I was kind of joking and also at
the whole time I was like,
I don't know what's,
what if this is a setup,
what if I'm here to talk to these 15
guys?
And then a hundred Klans members run out
of the woods to take down CNN.
You know,
this is before fake news trump.
But I was like,
I don't know,
so the whole time I was there I also
felt like this could go bad at any time
because when we pulled in there was a
guy holding a,
like a,
like a rifle and we told them no guns
and he was like,
well I don't believe I'm gonna bring my
gun.
And so it just felt like this could
turn.
I'm,
I'm not gonna do anything to turn it
badly,
but this could turn bad.
And so it felt like it felt the whole
time when I was making jokes with the
client and people go,
how could you make to the clan?
I was actually using self defense.
Like I was like,
because if you're making people laugh,
they generally.
And I wasn't making them laugh at my
expense.
I was just making them laugh about,
well that's weird.
Why do you burn this?
That it actually felt to me like I could
gain control of the situation.
Did you have any sort of reasonable
debate with them or report any back and
forth with them?
We like did.
Was there anybody that you kind of felt
like they saw how ridiculous it is?
No,
I mean I think we like,
I would like uh,
like I would make them laugh about
ridiculous things that were happening.
Like they were having a hard time,
uh,
like,
like getting the car,
getting care,
seen rags to wrap the cross in like,
and he was like,
I need to.
Clans went over here and I was like,
what do we have to do to get a went over
here?
And they're laughing,
but I'm like,
it's.
But there's not a sense of like,
here's what I felt like by the end I
knew some of those guys liked me in that
moment.
I felt like they laughed when I said
they were certainly trying to cheer me
up,
give me their business card.
You if you need any help,
find another class.
Because there's some when we're out here
that are full of Shit and you need to go
to the real.
Like there's.
So there's that level of rapport.
Oh.
So there's like,
there's factions that disagree with
other faculty.
Like it's like,
I feel like it's very similar to martial
arts school.
This is the real,
the real karate.
So like,
uh,
even though did you guys start at the
same school but he didn't get the real
stuff,
so.
Oh boy,
uh,
yeah.
So,
but they were very chummy at the end,
but also I was like,
I don't get the fuck out of here.
But I did feel like some of these guys
went to bed that night going a lot of
fun.
Now I'm not saying that like they
dropped the clan thing because I didn't
come back the next day,
but they were like,
you know,
I,
I left there feeling like I wonder if I
came back like in it,
you know,
six months to stroll through and was
like,
hey guys,
or are you wonder if you guys are on
some sort of reality show where it's
talking on an island for six months?
Yeah,
I mean I think a lot.
I mean the reason why big cities are
more generally more liberal than the
surrounding areas is because everybody's
on top of each other.
Right?
It just because everybody's on it.
I don't have time to hate you because
you make it.
I like your Bodega,
you know,
I don't have time to become accustomed
to each other and you realize it's just
people.
And then you also see the benefits of
that thing.
Like,
Hey,
the Puerto Rican day parade is fun.
You know what I mean?
Like it's like the,
your life experiences,
your are benefited by the fact that
you're surrounded by lots of different.
That is really interesting when you put
it that way.
I mean you do find that the bigger
cities tend to be way more liberal like
New York and La in particular.
Certainly more liberal than the
surrounding areas.
Like Houston is a blue dot,
but it's not as blue as like Berkeley is
the surrounding areas.
Much different sugar land out there.
Yeah.
You get.
Yeah,
you go out there,
the ranches
crisp enough or run or are you a.
You know,
so I think that to me that's what the
whole thing is,
is that just not.
You don't have enough.
You don't get the benefit of having a
diverse community because you're like,
which Chinese restaurant do I want to go
to and you want to go to the Chinese
restaurant that's run by the Chinese
family who was like,
this was a bad idea.
Well,
it's also the fear.
Know the fear of the other when you're
not around them.
I think if you were around people all
the time that are all sorts of different
people,
it just,
you find assholes that are white and
cool people that are brown and just sort
of go,
oh,
they're just humans.
We just were terrified and so we lump
off into groups.
So we somehow or another,
I have people that we relate to.
Well,
I mean,
I think it's a whole thing about like we
are,
we are,
we have fear of the unknown and somehow
I fear of the unknown is the fear that
somehow that unknown thing is going to
hurt us or affect us in some negative
way.
It's,
I mean,
you know,
when Obama first went into the White
House,
I would have lost money on get out of
marriage equality,
gay marriage.
I lost month,
like I was like,
that's not going to happen.
That's,
you know,
I,
there was no,
I didn't have a,
I would have put 50 years,
you know what I mean?
Really?
Why?
Just because I thought that ball was
moving in that direction anyway,
but I still wouldn't have thought that
it was going to happen in his,
within his pr.
I first I just did.
First of all,
I'm not the issue he came in campaigning
on,
so it wasn't like something that was.
I didn't think it was on his,
on anybody's agenda.
I knew it was on some people's agenda.
There were people working on it,
but I didn't think it wasn't something
that was like,
we didn't,
the combination didn't set that as a
goal.
It wasn't like a thing,
like obamacare was like we need to fix
this.
So it sort of happened in a way that
like the people worked behind the scenes
to make it happen and then it just sort
of woke up one day and opened our phones
up and it was like,
it's legal weight.
What?
Federally?
Yeah,
federal.
yeah,
yeah.
Like you just sort happened.
You're like,
wait,
wait.
I thought nothing.
That's it.
That was one of the most disappointing
things about hillary is that she didn't
up until 2013,
she didn't support marriage equality.
Yeah.
And I mean Obama was,
you know,
he had the thing that he sort of stopped
talking about it for a series of years
and then eventually it was like Joe
Biden was like,
I'm with it.
And Obama had to be like,
God dammit show.
Yeah.
I'm with it too.
I wasn't ready to say it yet.
Touchy subject amongst some people,
but it.
Yeah.
But I think,
and it still is among some people,
there's certainly people's country,
but it's,
there's a critical mass of people who
are like,
it doesn't actually affect me.
Right.
And right now we're going through that
with trans people in bathrooms.
Like it doesn't,
it doesn't actually affect you,
you know,
people transmit,
we go into the bathroom for the entire
existence that there've been bathrooms.
You just didn't know.
It doesn't actually affect you.
You know,
and I think you think it,
you were sort of saying,
this is weird to me,
this is scary to me,
so it's wrong,
but it's like,
no,
it's just weird and scary to you.
Those feelings are just feelings of the
unknown down now.
The assess the threat that that woman
goes to the bathroom.
She have gone to the bathroom.
Like there's not a threat that's coming
after you.
Well,
I think people are scared of people
taking their clothes off,
but that's what it is with the generals
are going to be exposed and they just
kinda go crazy.
Yeah.
But they're.
The generals already were like,
it's cool.
We just need bodies.
Like,
you know,
like the military was already had
already accepted trans people.
They're like,
we just need bodies.
We need people here who are good
soldiers or the military ones.
Real weird because he's a.
He apparently did that while the
hurricane was hitting.
Yeah,
he see pardoned.
Our Pio did that and there was one other
thing that he did that I'm not exactly
sure what it was.
He started bringing up again recently.
Controversial things.
Yeah.
Trying to get Mexico to pay for the
wall.
I could,
don't do think the Mexicans would be
paying for an education,
take care of the poor people.
So a lot of issues they have to take
care of.
Didn't have time for your father and
there's just no way you can make them
pay for the wall.
There's not,
it's not a thing you can't,
you know.
I mean,
unless we're talking about invading
Mexico instead of going into the banks,
you know,
like it's that we're talking about you.
Have you heard about the wall being a
gigantic solar panel?
One of the ideas to pay for the wall.
The wall would be a gigantic solar power
to generate electricity and pay for it.
Oh that's,
that's.
But then he'd have to accept solar
panels.
Try to run into problems with the coal
folks.
Yeah.
Some people just want to burn trees,
chop trees down.
Mike Cole.
Yeah.
So,
so for me,
the back,
the whole thing with the show is like,
it's for me,
it's not about me coming to agreement
with people.
Sometimes it's people like I do agree
with,
but I don't know your issue a lot,
so I'd like to talk to you about it.
It's just about the fact to me it's like
it's about we're going to have this
conversation.
People are gonna Watch this conversation
and that will create more conversation.
Well,
you're getting this weird opportunity.
Be Key to be again,
like I'm saying that you're you like I
know you,
so when I see you on tv,
I'm like,
oh,
that's,
you know,
that's normal for a television show.
Do you notice when people take on the
host of whether it's the tonight show or
one of those kinds of shows,
they automatically become this different
thing than they usually are.
They become like the host of a show,
and for me that the reason that is is
because there wasn't a.
like,
we're not,
there's not a ton of these shows out
there,
right?
So there's not like.
It's like,
oh,
come on,
I've got that show.
It's like talk shows the minute I got
totally biased.
Suddenly I'm seeing articles about the
tonight show,
the late,
late,
late show and totally biased,
wait what?
And then I'm being compared to those
people and I'm being judged against
like,
well last night fallon lip sync with
Justin timberlake about talked to
Laverne Cox.
That's not the same thing.
So I,
I read,
that's why I didn't like about that is
that people were suddenly defining me
against that thing and I was not.
And I would look at that show and be
like,
that's not me.
And I had friends who watch the show and
be like,
that's not me.
And then we'd write things for the show
and I'd say things like this,
I don't believe this,
you know,
or I don't feel as passionately about
this as the show makes me think,
I feel about this because we just have
to get the show done.
Whereas with this show I can go,
no,
I'm not saying that or I or I really
want to say this and I can rewrite
things and I can go,
yeah.
So totally biased.
You did in front of an audience and it
was more of A.
I don't think that that form works.
I don't think that's a good way.
I don't think for anybody.
I don't think it's a good way to have
meaningful conversations.
No giant groups of people and yeah,
everybody's clapping.
Yeah.
So you're trying to like play to them to
make a good point.
So you're not necessarily expressing
yourself like what would this,
what are the,
what are the real thoughts going on in
my mind as much as you're just trying to
get those points,
get laughs and I.
Yeah,
and the thing that I,
and I give credit to Chris rock for this
because he's the one who made me do the
man on the street segments on totally
biased.
He was like,
you need to get out there and people
don't know who you are.
You need to mix it up with the people.
And I was like,
I don't like.
I really didn't like whenever I saw
people who were on the street,
it was always like,
hey dummy,
why'd you stop and talk to me?
He
doesn't have a lot going on and you
decided to be nice and stuff and talk to
me.
Now I'm going to punish you for it.
Uh,
aside from billy on the street.
I think that's the version of it that I
feel like it's like he's had those
people get to have fun with it.
Billy on the street.
Uh,
billy eichner never wash that.
I mean it's just whenever I see that I
go,
he sort of,
he's the joke.
He's not making,
you know,
it's not like the thing,
like what year was the war of 18,
12.
You idiot,
you know?
And so I feel like I'd only seen it that
way.
So when I did,
when I did it,
I was always like,
just trying to like let them talk.
And then if they got the joke I would
tag the joke or if I thought of
something funny,
it wasn't necessarily against them.
It was,
it was about something situation that
was funny.
And so that trained me for united
shades,
the United States with the show.
I think that's the.
I think that's the only show I could
ever do.
Like I can't,
there's not other shows in me where I
would be on camera like that.
There's,
I'm not an actor.
I'm not trying to get a sitcom.
Not.
There's always a refreshing.
Yeah.
I just don't have any interest.
I'm not trying to audition for movies.
I don't audition for anything good for
you.
Live in Berkeley,
so I don't even,
I'm not even available to audition for
things.
Uh,
so,
but this I'm like,
yeah,
it's this or versions of this.
But the thing was,
it was basically in my mind it was based
on like the board Dane model and Morgan
spurlock's work and like,
and like even like Michael Moore's work
where I'm like,
those things are about them that like
when you watch,
it's about,
it's about this person and you'd watch
board if you'd like more day and you'd
watch them do anything.
It's not just about where he's going,
it's like about,
I just want to hang out with this dude
for an hour because I feel like with
with united shades,
the more it becomes that I just want to
able to come out for an hour,
then that's the show I want it to be.
Yeah.
Well you figured out a way to do it,
man,
and Kudos to CNN for allowing you to
just be yourself.
Yeah.
There's people always ask all the time,
how much pushback do you get?
I think the most pushback we got last
season was I had.
We had to fart jokes in the show and
they're like,
you have to pick one.
You can
was pretty fast.
I'm like,
what?
Their different fart jokes.
I didn't intentionally right to fart
jokes in the show.
It just.
We had presented with two opportunities
before jokes.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
so it was like.
So they were like,
but it's never like.
They actually did not want to be clear
on this.
They want the show.
I'm always want the show to be smarter.
They want the show to be smarter.
I want the facts to be vetted and clear.
They want that.
They want the journalistic integrity
because it's on a news network,
but they don't pitch angles like they,
for example,
they were like,
you know,
have you thought about doing anything
with Asian,
the Asian American community.
That was what they said.
And I was like,
I'd like to talk about Chinatown,
you know what I mean,
so that I get to take their suggestion
and put it into a and put it into my
version of it and that in.
And I was like,
I'd like to take it to talk about
Chinatown in San Francisco so I can film
an episode near my house and I have to
travel and I'd like to meet Shannon Lee.
Can we.
Did Shannon Lietz Lee's daughter?
Yeah.
That's cool.
So it was like I got to make the version
of the show I wanted while at the same
time talking about the history of
Chinatown and doing this other thing,
but it ended with me.
The last line is like,
you know,
I really learned a lot this week.
Who am I kidding?
I just wanted to become friends with
Shane and leave it because I'm a
comedian.
I can do that,
have some sort of like,
you know,
this and I sort of sometimes the people
who write like,
because people will write parts of the
show and they will write it like the way
journalists would do it this week.
I've learned that people come together
and there's some of that that's still I
have to keep sort of pulling out like
right to do write monologues or do you
just talk a there?
What happens is like with somebody they
will,
right,
like sort of the version of the script
and then I will get that and then
sometimes I will pull whole sections out
and then.
And then once we get into the Vo booth,
it's me and usually a couple of the
comedians like Ethan Berlin,
a drawn,
gee,
this season's gonna be doing Kennedy who
will then we'll sit in the.
We'll will be on the phone together on
the Vo booth and sort of like riff other
things out.
Yeah.
So it's great to actually be able to
hire because I had to clear with seeing
I need to hire comedians on the show.
It can't just be me and the news people
or the TV people.
Well it seems like it's not just a show,
but also an opportunity for you to just
sort of broaden your experience with
human beings.
Which is interesting.
I mean we went to Barrow,
Alaska in the first season.
What is that?
Where is that at?
The northern most tip of Alaska.
It's inside the Arctic Circle.
Ci's nobody visits barrel.
Like it's not a,
not like a parts of Alaska where like
anchorage.
Well No,
let's go visit.
It's not a place where it doesn't do
tourism you.
I mean you could go but there's nothing
to do there.
Just some of the year.
Did you go.
We went in,
I think it was,
it was,
it was spring in the rest of America,
but it was still like,
you know,
deep snow on the ground and frozen and.
But it was like,
it was like negative toward his right
there.
Choose inside the Arctic Circle.
Like we actually walked so far north
that we were on the ocean,
but it was still frozen,
you know,
like,
oh,
we're on the ocean.
And it was just still.
Yeah,
we were like on standing on the water.
What did you do there?
Uh,
it was the idea that,
well that was the idea because we just
don't have here where,
where have you never been.
Like,
sometimes that's how we for if you've
never been right,
we should go to Alaska.
Well isn't that just go to regular
Alaska?
Let's go,
let's go to the part of Alaska that even
that even like we went to anchorage for
part of it and even Alaskans don't go to
barrow because there's,
it's not,
it's a place where people go there to
work for the oil companies.
People work for companies that work for
the old company.
So it's not like.
And it's like,
so it's a camp to camp,
but it's,
you know,
it's 4,000 people in Anchorage is a
weird community anchorage.
When I was there,
one of the first things I saw when we
were driving a rental car to the hotel
was a group of people standing on the
corner holding up signs saying honk for
equality
and all these people were honking as
they drove by and there was like all
these people with purple hair and shit.
And I was like,
oh,
this is like a real city.
Yeah,
no,
anchorage has.
I mean it's like Bakersfield.
It's not,
it's cool when I was there.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's like a,
it's a real.
It's like you don't.
For me,
the only thing was it was,
it was cold but it wasn't even colder in
other place.
And there was like,
there was more salmon choices,
like everything.
Everywhere you went they were like.
And we have salmon.
Halibut.
Yeah.
And we have jerky,
salmon jerky.
So it was like,
it was,
that's why I'm glad we went to barrow
because Barrow is like,
like I loved it and I was like,
I'll never come back here again.
Like there's no way,
unless I was doing something and you
know,
so that for me,
like that's what is fun and that episode
was people like that episode a lot.
I thought it was because it's not.
Sometimes people think the episode,
the show is just me talking to scary
people,
but most of the show is just me talking
to people that I've never talked to
before.
Just getting a chance to see America.
Yeah.
And like,
you know,
so we did an episode about Lucy,
some of Muslims,
but it's like,
well that's a big topic,
but we went to Hamtramck in Dearborn,
Michigan at this super small town,
the highest percentage of Arabs and
Muslims in America,
like 30 percent Arabs and Muslim in this
town and it's like a sleepy suburb where
you just happen to see lots of women in
Hijab walking around like,
you know,
but it's,
you sort of feel like,
is this right?
You know what I mean?
This seems weird.
It's just like,
it's just a sleepy suburb outside of
Detroit or inside of Detroit.
There's ham generics in the middle of
Detroit and it's just this small town
that happens to be because of,
uh,
the Ford factory,
like some of the things that happens a
lot with immigrants like the,
like the Ford factory was okay hiring
immigrants back in the day or Muslims
back in the day.
So the Muslims were like,
everybody come here.
And so then it became a very popular,
a very populous Arab Muslim town.
But it's like,
and then I got to sit down with a woman,
her name was [inaudible] and I just got
to ask her all the dumb questions about
it,
about Islam and all the dumb questions
about,
about her job and in Burkas and you
know,
and how that works with feminism.
Can you be a feminist and a Muslim woman
who can you be a feminist and a woman
who is wearing a burka?
And she's like,
yeah,
you can.
It's a choice,
you know,
so I mean,
you know.
So I think that.
And then we got to talk about,
well,
what about in Saudi Arabia?
And they go,
the government of Saudi Arabia does a
lot of shit that's wrong and they use
Islam as a way to justify it.
Just like the way the American
government does a lot of shit that's
wrong and says God and country.
It's not about the religion,
it's about the expression of the
religion.
So,
you know,
for me it's like to be able to ask those
dumb questions.
We got to go to standing rock in the
middle of standing rock.
And so while it was going through the
pipeline,
the height of it,
yeah.
Wow.
What was that like?
Did you get hosed?
No,
I was.
I was there for a few hours.
This was not.
This was the sort of at the big sort of
the first,
third of it I guess.
So it was still not.
It had not turned into that and we were
very disturbing time because they were
going through people's public or private
land and they were saying,
look,
no,
we're going through and,
but what is private land then?
Yeah,
if you just can decide to have your
business go through my land and dig a
fucking pipeline that may or may not
poisoned my wells if everything goes
wrong.
Like what is public land?
What does private is this,
is it all the governments land or they
just usurping my private land like this
kind of fucking.
The native people are like,
yeah,
this is what they do to us.
This is what.
This is how they are.
Yeah,
they're there.
Whatever the whatever the number of
treaties that.
Because people get.
There's like several hundred treaties
and they're like,
they've broken all of them,
like not like half of them they say
they've broken all of the treaties,
so the native American people,
that's why they had to make a big noise
because like this is how they do and
this was like,
it felt like the final Straw and so they
were people like we got there before the
winter and they were like,
there's people in tps were like it.
I had this whole conversation about how
tb beefs think of Tbi.
I thought if teepees is like,
you're going to have teepees in the
winter,
like yeah,
they're better than tense.
Like they're just,
this is a hole in the top and you can
have a fire in the middle of.
Yeah,
I knew you would know,
but I was like,
really?
And this guy was like,
this guy was like,
yeah.
And then I said to this one guy,
I'm like,
well,
what do you do if it gets really,
really cold?
Go to the hotel down the street.
Oh,
you know,
like it's just like I was in this whole
like native
when we go to,
we go to the restaurant,
you know what I mean?
So it's like it.
And it was.
That was one of my favorite episodes
because I get to sit and ask all the
dumb questions that I've had and other
people have and sometimes I ask dumb
questions that I kind of know the answer
to you.
Would that be like we need to ask the
dumb question when we have an
opportunity to don't go tap into people
in line at starbucks and asking them
dumb questions.
You got the Dakota pipeline was
extremely disturbing and it just because
it was just was one of the clearest
examples of money overwrites,
money over land ownership,
money over everything.
We're going through with this thing.
It's gonna make us money and this is
what we're going to do.
You should get Tara.
Tara Houska on here.
She's a,
she was at standing rock and she speaks
very awesome about all this stuff and
she's a hardcore activist.
She was one of,
she was like Bernie Sanders,
native American,
the representative,
but uh,
and she's great about all this stuff and
you can talk about how to them.
It's like,
this is just the most recent expression
of this.
Spell her name t a r t a r a h o u s k
there is,
there she is.
Yeah,
she,
I mean she was in the episode and when
we sat down I was like,
I'm going to ask you a bunch of dumb
questions.
She was like,
great.
Here we go and talked about like,
this is just the tip of the iceberg.
Where is that now?
Where's that standard?
Because when trump got in office,
he paid,
apparently greenlit everything.
There's still people fighting against
it,
but it's not the same,
you know,
number of people out there,
but they're still active.
She will be able to tell you more better
than I would,
but they're still,
you know,
they're still the same.
There's still people fighting,
but they're going through it anyway.
Right.
They're going right under the river.
And again,
this is where it gets a little bit out
of my depth.
But yeah.
Yeah.
What is there,
what was like the.
I mean I don't think there's any one
thing that was most rewarding to you,
but there was anything that you got the
most out of during that show during the
native Americans,
you know,
doing your show.
United States of America.
Uh,
the bay,
the San Quentin episode is actually the
one that I feel like has actually
affected me the deepest that I've been
back to St Winton twice,
maybe three times,
twice since then.
I cohosted it like a talent showcase
with one of the inmates.
Really?
Yeah.
We were like on stage together,
like he wrote bits for us to do and yet
I was ripping,
you know,
and it's this thing where like,
believe me,
even though I had gone to San Quintin
and filmed either,
I went to St coat and film the show.
I was like,
I walked in like this is,
this was in the episode.
I walked in with the,
one of the,
like the coordinator,
the junior warden,
I'm going to guess,
and Sam,
and he was like,
we walk in to the,
to the yard,
and he was like,
how do you feel?
And I'm like,
because we're walking into the yard
like,
you know,
and it's all inmates doing sit ups and
pushups and hanging out playing
basketball.
And he goes,
how's it feel like?
Oh,
it feels like walk into a neighborhood
that don't know anybody.
Like you know,
like if one of the neighbors were,
you're like,
I need to be careful here.
And then as I was saying that some guy
goes,
love your comedy Bro.
And I go,
oh,
it feels pretty good.
And it was.
Then that's exactly what happened.
And we left it in the show and then from
that point forward it was just like if
you,
if you like sort of close your eyes,
it was just talking mostly to black men
who've had a lot of life experience and
been through a lot of shit and who have
learned a lot from them,
what they went through and have like
done therapy and self actualized and
educated themselves and all these types
of things.
And then if,
but then you realize that I'm never
going to leave.
They have a lot of experience out of
wealth,
of knowledge,
a lot of skills and they're never going
to leave.
And so for me it was like I can do more
here.
So I went back,
we screened the episode there.
It was the most tense screening I ever
had because like what if they hate it,
but they were like cheering and clapping
and gave me a standing ovation at the
end.
And so I went back and hosted this
talent show.
And again I went back and still like,
well what if this time?
And they're like,
ah,
come on.
When they make fun of me,
because I could.
I did not pay A.
Was it a pinnacle?
They were still,
yeah,
to play peanuckle in prison.
I know how to play and they're like,
you're a black man.
Doesn't play peanuckle like they were.
And they're like,
oh,
it's just one of those crazy card games.
It's way too complicated that you know,
and the.
They said we play peanuckle because it's
really complicated and takes a lot of
time.
You don't want to just play like war in
prison.
You want to play a game that's really
complicated so it actually sort of fills
the time you have.
I had a friend who went to prison and
learned how to play chess in his head.
Yeah,
you can just yell out the Rook to King
Five checkmate him and this other kid
who was a chess genius or sitting down
this ex con and this chess genius
sitting down playing chess in their head
in front of me.
And I was like,
wow,
this is crazy.
And it reminds me.
It's like the autobiography of Malcolm
X.
Malcolm x said there's all this wisdom
in the neighbor in the,
in the hood that these can be
mathematical geniuses,
these can be the people who cure cancer,
but they can't.
They're not being put in positions where
they can actually use.
You can take advantage of this.
Yeah,
and also mistakes like whatever mistake
you make when you're a young person,
whether it's selling drugs or shooting a
gun in the air for your third offense,
there's certain mistakes that
automatically disqualify you from any
personal growth for the rest of your
life.
Like that's it.
Like you are now contained and
incarcerated.
Yeah,
and there'll be no growth.
Yeah.
And the thing is the same.
It should be a really small list of
things that disqualify you from society
for the rest of your life.
Especially like at 18.
It should be a.
There are things,
but it should be a pretty small finance
ministers.
Yeah,
it should be.
Yeah.
It should be like you are a monster that
we should still check in with you every
20 every night.
I'm going to go,
are you still a monster?
Like how's it going?
Is there a pill to being a monster?
If we,
if we sort of put you in therapy and
educate you,
are you still going to be a monster?
We should still be working on these
people,
but it's certainly not in a fish.
It's not,
it's not for the betterment for society
that we've taken this huge pool of
people out of the prison system and as
you know,
this is the thing.
Black people are like 12 percent of the
American population were 40 percent
American prison population.
Somewhere around there please google it
makes sure,
but it's not because we're doing 40
percent of the crime.
It's we black people do crime,
but we're over sentenced a lot of times.
We're not getting proper representation.
We're not A.
There's like the three strike laws,
so it's like something that like a white
guy in Nebraska does.
A black guy doesn't California,
so he's in prison the rest of his life.
You know what I mean?
Like it's like we're not getting the,
the unequal application of the law,
which ends up putting us in prison at a
higher rate.
And isn't there more people in
population in prison in America than the
rest of the world's presence in the.
If you look at the graph of like
Americans per the number of people in
prison,
it goes like,
it's like,
it stays pretty constant for a long
time.
And then like right around the 80 years
ago,
we have like some,
like somewhere between two and 3 million
people in prison.
The agent,
it goes,
you know,
you can pull it up,
but he goes through laws that,
that caused that to.
It's like mandatory minimums and uh,
incarcerated Americans.
Wow.
Look at that 1980 something.
It just launches straight up.
Yeah.
And it completely vertical on.
And it's like,
it wasn't like people were committing
the same crime.
Like man,
people just create so many more crimes.
It's just about why we were keeping them
in prison longer.
Look at that shit.
In the 19 seventies it was less.
Look at the number,
less than a million people.
And let's talk about this,
we're talking about the 19 seventies,
that's the Scorsese,
Scorsese movie at crime and crime is at
the streets of New York.
And then solid 1970,
it looks like like 400,000 people in
prison,
right?
If that's half a million,
that looks like somewhere around
400,000.
That's fucking insane.
And now it's millions.
And again,
it's not because crime got so much
worse.
It was that we started to private
prisons made it that we need to keep
people in here.
We need to hold.
This is the,
we're making money where this is a
moneymaking enterprise,
so we need to keep people in here.
The real problem is once you've got
something like that going on,
pulling that back,
it's going to be extremely difficult
when there's profit to be made from
incarcerating people.
Yeah,
and I mean there's the,
uh,
there's a guy,
Shane Bauer,
I've heard the name,
he works for Mother Jones magazine.
He was one of those guys that gets on
the ground and.
But he did a whole thing where he was a
prison guard in Louisiana.
He applied for a job as a prison guard
at a for profit prison in Louisiana.
Wow.
Just for the story,
just for the story and didn't hide his
identity.
Where do you work?
Mother Jones magazine.
We.
We need people like they didn't do any
sort of big background check and he was
a huge article.
He did a couple of years,
like a year or so ago about being a
prison guard and it stayed.
I mean if you read it,
it's like the things you can get away
with when you are the prison guard and
the ways in which you can treat people
at this prison in Louisiana are just.
It's like,
you know,
it's a nightmare and this prison is
supposed to be about rehabilitation
that's not.
And it's not and especially at a for
profit and for profit prisons that he's
another guy you should have on.
I'm booking your podcast.
Please do.
Yeah.
The amount of money that they spend is
directly related to the amount of money
they earn.
So just trying to feed you with the
cheapest fucking food that can get into
what this is about.
And also it's about keeping you in line.
It's not about keeping you,
you know,
it's not about,
it's not about helping you,
it's about keeping you in La.
I mean,
in the San Quentin episode,
I went to the mess hall with him and got
and had the food,
the dinner and it was like,
first of all,
none of it is,
it's like the,
it's like the worst level of food.
Like it just like peas,
carrots,
like not like there's no salt,
there's no mess,
there's no taste to it.
And then like a,
uh,
an uh,
a hot dog like that with a bunch to the
hot dog,
San Quintin's,
the prison that every prisoner wants to
graduate to in California.
And so a lot of the guys end up like
illegally bringing food in and then
making food together in their cells
because they are like,
I can't eat this,
this is not,
this is not good for you,
you know?
And also dinner's at 5:00 so I can you
and you eat at 5:00 and you know,
nobody's going to bed at six and was
still hungry.
So you're still late,
it's like,
you know,
so like 10:00 at night,
you're hungry.
You have to have figure out a different
way to make something happen.
And what's also fucked is that you get
like thirty cents an hour or something
like that for working.
And you know why that is,
is because of the,
the emancipation proclamation didn't
apply to prisoners.
Really?
Yeah.
So that's why you can pay prisoners
thirty cents an hour.
Oh beautiful.
We're going to talk about fun things
would happen.
It happened to me some fun shit.
What did you do that was fun?
Like what'd you enjoy?
Uh,
what did I enjoy?
we did Puerto Rico,
Puerto Rico because I just had Peter
Schiff on.
He moved all his money over to Puerto
Rico because you don't have to pay
taxes.
Oh yeah,
the 40,
the whole thing of Puerto Rico.
So strange.
But it's a,
to me the fact Puerto Rico's bankrupt,
it's like $80,000,000,000 or some sort
of crazy figure of debt and it's.
And it's just because the US has used
Puerto Rico,
like,
you know,
like as a,
as like,
it's like the ATM,
you know,
we sort of did things there and we
didn't because it wasn't a state,
we didn't have to sort of do it the same
way,
but it is one of the most beautiful
places I've ever been in my life.
And I mean I was there like the show
runner,
Dion Jackson was,
he'd been there before,
he's like there's houses for $25,000.
And I was like calling my wife,
we should just,
we don't own a house in California.
We should,
you know,
like it was,
it's such a fun,
beautiful place that has been exploited
by the United States of America by not
being a state and not being independent
country.
Like it's weird to like stings aren't
allowed to ship directly to Puerto Rico.
They have to ship to the United States
and then go to Puerto Rico so that
everything is super expensive.
Super expensive.
But it's like,
for me it's like,
it's like being in a foreign country but
your cell phone works.
So it's like,
so you get all the,
like different culture and new food and
you get all the like know the people
speak Spanish so if you speak a little
bit of Spanish you can get by.
It's a super diverse place.
So like I as a guy who's married to a
white woman with a,
with a couple of mixed race kids,
we don't feel like we stick out there,
you know,
they're just sort of like.
And the weather was,
I was like,
I was,
I want to,
I want to go back so badly.
Like loved it.
I loved it and I don't like stuff.
Do you think you could live there?
I think it could retire there.
I think it was all said and done.
I think I could be like,
I think at this point it'd be hard,
but I certainly think if I liked was an
east coast life maybe because there's a
lot of people,
a lot of Puerto Ricans who live in New
York who have houses in Puerto Rico.
But then I also feel weird because I'm
not Puerto Rican.
Like am I a gentrifier?
Am I making it better by this house for
$25,000 that helping you or is that
actually fucking you over?
So
I bought this $25,000 to be conscious of
that stuff.
I believe you have to be conscious of
that.
So I think if I did it I would.
But I met a.
I met the governor of Puerto Rico who is
not very popular,
but I was happy to talk to you a
governor.
So.
But you know the whole battle is over
statehood in the,
in to they want it like it's really a
disputed thing.
Most many activists don't want it
because they feel like why are we,
why are we sort of being subjugated by
the United States?
Why can't we were on country?
But the problem is they're like
$80,000,000,000,000,
like whatever it is there so much in
debt.
It's like what happens?
But it feels like to me like it's an,
it's,
it's like,
it's like it's Hawaii,
it's Hawaii,
but it's also,
it's like Hawaii,
but it's like if we hit it doesn't make
sense.
It's in debt is what I'm saying.
It doesn't make sense that it feels like
this is a beautiful place.
This is,
this could be if you just taking
advantage of what it looks like,
this place,
you'd be making a lot of money.
He just has a resort,
a resort.
This is a place to like and it done the
right way.
They should be making money hand over
fist.
So I started to,
I invest in Puerto Rico.
That's what,
that's what I do with my buddy.
But I really could be an east coast guy
though if you've lived,
uh,
all this time on the west coast,
I can be,
I can do well the Puerto Rico,
Puerto Rico's not the east coast.
That's different than if you'd have to
either live there all about what time
all told I,
I'm talking about,
I'm talking about that version of me
that ends up with like some sort of
like,
that somehow ends up with Kevin Hart
money without working as hard as Kevin
Hart or somehow something happens where
you go,
man,
it's weird that I invested in that,
you know,
that,
that shoelace company.
And now those shoelaces are everywhere.
You know,
then it would be like,
I'm gonna,
go to Puerto Rico,
I'll go to Puerto Rico.
I would certainly spend some time there.
And if you go to Puerto Rico though and
you move all your business to Puerto
Rico,
you moved your money.
Puerto Rico,
you don't have to pay taxes.
I believe me,
I'm,
I'm with real weird.
It's my wife.
That would not be.
She's the West coaster and she,
she would not be done for that.
But I do think about going back.
I was hoping we could screen in episode
there,
the Puerto Rico episode there cause it
was a lot of fun.
But seeing how many episodes have you
done so far?
We've done 16.
It's a to season.
Wow.
And so we're about to start.
We start filming season two,
like September third.
Pumped.
Uh,
yeah.
I'm excited.
I mean it's been,
it's weird because last season when the
show went off the air I felt like I
could tell that like people didn't.
They sort of talk about the show had
gone away.
But the trump era is good for business.
How?
How so what do you mean?
Like you felt that the talk had gone
away,
just like,
you know,
when you're,
when you're like when you fear special
comes out and you're walking around
town,
more people may recognize you more
people and then when you're specials not
out it's not,
you know,
sometimes the volume gets turned down.
But with this I still walk around and
it's like the show is still on the air,
people are still talking about the show
and they see me,
there's a sense of like,
oh,
like they really feel the show in a very
deep way.
Like I hear from people like families
watch the show together and like,
you know,
and I didn't make it for that reason so
it,
so it feels like the show,
the first season show Obama was still in
office.
So I felt like that was like the mixed
tape and the first season was like the,
the second seems like the album and
it's,
I feel like now like people are looking
for the show in a different way.
So it feels like knowing that I have to
make sure the show steps it up a notch.
So that's,
that's the,
I feel the pressure,
like make sure that we don't just,
I'm like,
I don't want to make the show like which
white supremacist he going to talk to
you this season,
but we have to do other things.
It can't just be,
we can't be repeating.
That's interesting.
So you feel like a sense of
responsibility,
not just to entertain but also to Kinda
like get some ideas out there that maybe
would reach people and maybe I just,
I feel like we're as comedians were all
responsible to our material,
you know what I mean?
And so I feel like in that sense I'm not
doing anything different than Jim
Gaffigan's doing.
You know what I mean?
Like there's,
these are the things I want to talk
about.
These are the things you want to go,
things I want to talk about.
You're not Jim,
not Jim Gaffigan.
Yes,
but it's.
But I feel like I don't want to.
I don't want to separate myself from.
It's easy to somehow I believe in the
work that I'm doing.
I'm excited about the work I'm doing.
I do think that the work can help
lubricate changes.
I don't.
It's not the change,
but I don't want to get caught up in
like the sort of like this is important.
You know what I mean?
Because I just feel like at the end of
the day,
people often say to me like,
do you still consider yourself a
comedian?
Yes.
I'm a comedian.
I still do stand up.
I'm trying to work on my next special,
like I'm still trying to do these
things.
It's fun to be.
It's fun to say funny things.
I just like to say funny things about
these things.
Yeah.
Well you also,
you're a part of this giant discussion
whether you're a comedian or an author
or journalist,
you're a part of this giant discussion
which is human culture and I think we
need people that are articulate and
thoughtful on all sides.
We need to like figure out that there's
going to be all styles of humans to
different things that people are
interested in,
but what's got to be the most important
thing about being an American is
respecting all the other styles of
human.
All the other ways people think whether
they're conservative
or whether they're liberal or whether
they're,
you know,
whether they choose to whatever the fuck
it is,
you want to live off the land in Alaska
or whether you want to be in Manhattan.
Well,
I mean,
you know,
whether you want to be in Alabama where
they want to be in Berkeley and I go to
both those places so I see all those
people.
So I think the thing is is like you and
you have to realize that this is
something is maybe makes you nervous or
scared.
It's not always about you.
And I think that's the big thing that
people get wrong about the bay area.
We're not all a bunch of liberal people
on the same page.
We just recognize that we all go out
there because it's like I just wanna go
someplace where I can do my own thing.
Just go meet some rich people in Marin
county if you think that.
Exactly,
yeah.
Yeah.
Or silicon valley is silicon valley or
those silicon valley people.
So weird though,
because they try so hard to go left
because it's almost like they feel like
they have to.
It's like a part of the business model.
Well,
a lot of them,
a lot of those people.
It's like when you're like,
wait,
did you really invent anything?
It wasn't like instagram wasn't that
facebook,
but just pictures like you know,
and you're like,
I'm.
So I feel like there's probably a lot of
silicon valley guilt in there too.
Oh,
just like the amount of money.
I said I'm just going to do the part
about facebook this picture now I have a
billion dollars.
You don't do the thinking and Zuckerberg
is going to run for president.
Trump has changed.
He's turned the table over.
He.
So I think in that sense.
Let's see.
Let's see what happens.
I think we definitely need new ideas,
but I'm not keeping for Duncan Berg,
right?
Yeah,
he could.
But yeah.
I don't know.
The world is better now than it was in
$1,900,
but it's a slow sort of gradual
evolution of human ideas,
you know?
And I think that shows like yours
contribute to that and then
conversations contribute to that and
getting just the,
this,
this thing is like one layer of paint at
a time.
We're trying to build a mountain.
You know,
it's just,
it's frustrating for people because they
want immediate change.
And I think the thing is this,
take that analogy,
sometimes you go,
oh,
that was the wrong color of paint.
We got to
get some errors,
errors.
And I think that right now I believe
we're going through an error and the
error era.
And uh,
I don't know though,
since I think like the,
the response to it has genuinely
energized people to look at the
surroundings,
look at politics,
look at the way we're governing this
civilization,
the way that we're interacting with each
other and try,
I mean the people that are responding to
these people walking down the street
with fucking home depot candles and
screaming out antisemitic slurs or
whatever the fuck they're doing that has
sort of energized people in that don't
agree with that.
It's sort of like step up and try to
understand how the fuck is this still
going on in 2017.
Like who are these people that we didn't
know existed?
Because you live in Santa Monica,
know that you don't,
you're not around any of that.
Everybody you know is pretty left wing.
Like what?
Who,
who are these people?
Like what,
what,
what part of us is represented in this
ugly aspect of our culture?
Whether it's,
you know,
people that hate white people or people
that hate black or people that hate
Jews or what is this like,
why is this still here?
What,
what has failed that this still exists.
And I think these conversations are a
big part mean.
What you're doing by doing your show is
your,
for millions of people that get to tune
in and they get to hear the words and it
adds layers to the way they understand
human beings.
That's,
it's so God damn important.
And for me it's like I appreciate you
saying that and for me there's a part of
this that is wholly just like,
I want to have these conversations.
I'm happy to see it in his budget to
make these conversations happen.
I've always wanted to sit down with the
engineer.
Yeah.
That's the engine that it forward
actually do want to have these
conversations and that's one of the
things that makes them just a authentic
to people that are watching the show.
I can tell when I watch your show like
this has come out,
like really being interested in it.
Yeah.
No I'm not.
And when I'm not interested we don't use
it,
you know,
like are we too,
are we really.
We really work hard to pick the right
people and you know,
there's debates like we had a whole
debate like what if we could get trump,
you know,
what'd you do?
I that I had,
I really pushed back.
I was like in there still.
I was like,
I don't believe because I believe he's
uncurious.
I don't believe there's any there there.
Would you,
would you ask him if he's on?
I'd rather,
but I don't think he would even take in
the question that I was at,
you know,
I'd rather Ivanka.
You know what I mean?
I'd rather like somebody who's actually
who I feel like it's like you can see
sometimes it's like,
this is not going according to plan.
You know?
I grew up with the Internet.
Yeah.
That would rather.
I would rather,
you know,
I mean,
I probably rather bannon,
you know what I mean?
Like I feel like I don't believe that
there's any,
there,
there were things would smell like
sulfur.
I've forgotten someone light a match.
I feel like he's going to probably carry
a cell phone in his pocket.
So he does smell like sulfur because he
wants to create the illusion that I am
the reckoning am all times.
Yeah.
That's like the Bhagavad Gita.
Become death world.
Like I think he probably,
you know,
that's why I hate it when starting live
made him,
the parody of him was like the grim
reaper.
He was like,
yeah,
yeah.
Good.
Yeah.
He's like,
that's what I am.
I am the grim reaper.
Right.
The Sean Spicer one was hilarious
because trump thought that Melissa
mccarthy doing it made him look like
woman who was doing.
There was a push at one point that Rosie
O'donnell do trump and I was like,
that would.
It would have been after she was done to
do what she talked about it.
It was so good at it.
That's great,
but I think about like Bob's great,
but I would have.
Rosie would've really hurt his feelings
and he probably would've.
Right.
Especially if you can.
She can say some dark,
dark shit.
I love the fact that spicer retired too.
When scaramucci got on board,
I was like,
that's it.
Yeah,
but then now they're scared when she's
gone.
Spicer hasn't been like,
can I have my job back?
He was like,
he would.
He has nobody's hurt.
Spicer go,
well,
I'm glad that I can finally returned to
my place.
She mentioned being the guy that has to
tell everybody that this was the biggest
crowd,
the White House for the first day and
soda.
You know that there's photos and you
like.
The first thing you want me to tell
people is a lie and you could see the
look in phases like this is a lot.
That's.
I really.
I have a soft spot in my heart for,
for Sarah Huckabee,
sanders,
because she like goes out there like
30 right now.
She thinks she's younger than that.
I think.
No,
I think she's.
I think she's starting to.
No,
I think she's in her mid thirties.
I think so,
but I don't know,
but I thought she was just 28 with hard
year.
I just feel like I liked the fact that
she's out there like the 25,
30,
35,
35.
I liked the fact that she's out there
like,
like you kind of know.
She knows it's.
I'm not blinking.
It makes.
She said when I bought,
when a brother a trump was a attacking
people on twitter,
she was like,
if you attack him,
he hits back 10 times harder.
I'm like,
Hey,
good.
What are you talking about?
You don't teach your children that are
not yet a boxer that's really good at
taking punches.
Yeah.
This is the president of the united,
so whatever happened to turn the other
cheek,
but there was a thing called
presidential,
but we thought that defined the person.
But now what we're learning is that the
person defines the word he's defining
what presidential is,
his supportive,
believe if he did it,
and this is what trump leads.
You can tell if I say it,
it's presidential.
If I say it,
then it's worthy of the president's
saying it.
So if me retweeting as he did the other
day,
like,
you know,
uh,
whatever,
with some sort of conspiracy theory
nonsense,
they don't means it's a legitimate
thing.
It has to be the president did it.
It's like the,
it's like the same thing with like the
monarchy in England.
Like if the Queen says it,
then that's what it is.
You know.
So this is where we're at.
It's a fascinating play if it didn't
have so much of an impact on our actual
wellbeing.
Yeah.
Know people told me about.
I was talking to a woman yesterday who
was a public school teacher and she was
saying or had been in public school
teacher and she's talking to other
folks,
will teachers about.
There are kids who go to school every
day who are,
who are born in this country,
you know,
they may be there from the Latino kids
were born in the country,
their parents were,
are undocumented and they go to school
every day for their parents are going to
be kicked out of the country and not
knowing what that does to them.
And now somebody is like,
why didn't you do your homework?
You know,
like,
it's like you're like,
because I have a lot going on right now,
you know,
why aren't you selling?
Well,
you got an attitude problem,
you know what I mean?
Like we're not sort of the trump doing
all that up their filters down to some
kid in a public school classroom who
gets in a fight and then they expelled
him because he's like,
he's got an attitude problem.
You know that it's like people are not
really.
People don't think enough about how this
is affecting regular ass people.
Well,
he's a role model.
Believe it or not because he's the
president and the president by
definition is aroma for sure.
I mean,
when you were a kid,
when I was in grade school,
I remember kids saying,
I want to be president some day,
and other kids going,
wow,
this motherfucker's reaching for the
stars in a while.
He wants to be the guy.
I think,
wow,
you know,
how difficult would that be?
But,
you know,
but then again I grew up with.
I remember like a grown up.
I remember when Reagan was in office and
I remember all my family be like,
you know what I mean?
So funny.
He was like,
hey,
not everybody.
Not Everybody.
A lot of people that were like that when
Reagan was in office,
which is so weird,
like the whole revisionist history thing
that happened like after he was dead.
Now he's the.
Yeah,
he's the,
the modern,
great president.
Do you guys remember the whole Ollie
North thing?
Do you guys remember Iran Contra?
Do you remember the guy standing in
front of the front of the court when
they were questioning him saying he
doesn't remember selling arms to Iran.
This is,
remember Nancy Reagan standing him,
feeding him to the next thing to say.
Yeah,
no,
I think that the.
So to me it's like I just in my lifetime
it's like people were like,
man,
right?
Like people I know ran Reagan was such a
bad precedent and then you get ga wish.
No,
that's a bad president.
And he gets through because I'm like,
well,
what's.
Yeah,
that's my.
this time doesn't end with trump.
You know what?
Let's,
let's see what's coming in.
And that's why I think when you say like
seeing how people react to trump and
stand up and in the streets,
to me it's like today they're doing that
or they did it this weekend,
but it's like some point people either
they get exhausted by doing that.
There's a march right now going from
Charlottesville to DC to protest you
trumps all the things that trump said in
the wake of walk the whole way.
Yeah.
Was a bunch of people on the way or pick
up some.
I think that's more likely.
Like people like that several days.
It's like a week long thing.
Yeah.
They're going to walk for several doing
right now as we're talking to people and
I think a lot of times those marches,
like the hardcore people start first and
then I might show up Saturday afternoon.
Hey guys,
we walked this whole
jump out of a trailer makeup all in
Charlottesville a few days ago,
but yes man,
we walked a long way.
Remember that fun adventure we had,
but there's people right now who are
walking from Charlottesville to defeat
because they're like saying we have to
sort of keep the pressure on,
but it's exhausting to do that.
Not everybody can do that.
I don't know how much it helps because I
remember the women's march totally on
acknowledged.
She never said a thing about it.
It's millions of people all over the
world marching against them.
People weren't pussy hats.
Nobody cared.
Just didn't.
Doesn't seem to respond.
I think sometimes it's not about like
whether the,
whether the people in power care,
it's whether the people care and it gets
people energized to do the next thing.
So I think that like,
you know,
the march on Washington that king did
didn't.
You can't go and the next day like you
can't,
but it certainly becomes a historical
moment that people didn't look for and
it also becomes like everybody,
not every but most people,
their homes that I were talking about
the women's March and it starts the
thing that like,
it's the same thing with marriage
equality,
like it starts to open up people's
brains,
so like,
ah man,
what were they talking about?
And some people are having bad
conversations,
but it's to me it's like it opens up as
long as you keep the conversation going,
there's a potential for change.
Yeah,
it just takes time.
So there's an old expression that comes
to gambling and also it can be applied
to weight loss and a bunch of other
things in life that you get better the
same way you got sick.
Like,
like with gambling,
like you can't just win it all back.
It takes,
you got to slowly try to chip away and
get back and it was weight loss.
You can't just lose all that weight.
It doesn't happen like that.
Like how long did it take you to get
fat?
Well,
guess what?
It's gonna take you a similar amount of
time,
maybe longer to lose them.
Could very well and I think for our
culture it's gonna take awhile
to sort all this out and I think we also
have a problem that the,
the actual operating system that we use,
this whole representative government
that was set up back when you had to
take a letter by horse to get to people
like it's really not necessary anymore
and it's.
It creates a lot of red tape and it
creates a lot of bureaucratic
inefficiency that I think if we had to.
We had no government right now we're
trying to structure a government.
The last thing we do is have one person
with incredible amount of power that
could also launch the nukes and pardon
criminals.
We wouldn't have that.
We'd never set that up like that.
We would put in like the offices with
cubicles that are in a semicircle,
probably have like a council of wise
presidential council with people,
people that are like math,
mathematics,
professors that understand economics and
people that understand geography and
understand cultural differences.
People that are,
you know,
that really understand healthcare that
really understand all the different
things we wouldn't to make like the
Supreme Court,
a lifetime appointment you would go,
you know,
you get it for 20 years and saying,
yeah,
you don't,
you don't.
And we wouldn't.
There's no.
This is the thing we don't think
Democrats focus enough on unless they're
doing it behind closed doors that you
would not have the electoral college no
fucking way.
He would not know.
Nobody can sell it to you.
Nobody could.
Nobody could tell you why it makes sense
now is important to me.
Settle down how important everybody's
important,
but it's even more important than
anybody else.
One person,
one vote,
man.
We're just,
yeah,
we're looking at this.
The whole thing,
like every election boils down to like
four or five states.
Crazy.
Like in California.
By the time the polls closed,
they tell you who won because like we
know how California voted.
So then I become a person who was like,
what was the point in me voting for
like,
you know,
so for me,
electoral college and then
gerrymandering where the whole thing
where they get to sort of,
they divide your neighborhood up into a
way that sort of fits the,
those are the things that are really,
that's why it's scary about who comes
after trump because as long as the
electoral college exists,
it automatically sort of tips the
country to more,
sort of right leaning direction,
you know?
And,
and now we just may be fine except when
the right becomes trump,
you know,
like,
if it's different,
if it's president John Mccain,
which I'm not a huge John Mccain fan,
but I feel like at least there's a
through line.
You know what I mean?
So for me it's like the electoral
college is never.
That's why the left has to fight so
hard.
And I feel like if you're not,
if Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer art in
hallways already meetings right now,
like fuck this electoral college,
have we got to take it down?
Then we're sort of losing the plot of
how this works.
Well,
I don't think it's necessary anymore and
this idea that,
well,
the people in the middle needed because
the people on the coasts,
the large population centers,
they can dictate.
Well,
yeah,
there's more
people there.
That's the actual country.
Yeah.
There's that.
That's why they
are out here.
Fucking our kids in the middle.
That's not what people did.
People define as most like we have more
people.
They're like,
well,
we got more land that's not the same.
Each of us.
We're all supposed to in this thing
together and it would be a way more
interesting war board election if
everybody knew that just counting the
votes and there's a Paul in the middle
and politics would have to work way
harder instead of going,
well,
I'm not gonna.
Go talk to people in the up and down
California because that's already set.
You don't think there's an issue with
states to or think there's an issue with
people voting like we lost California
and Nevada has gone to.
You know,
how does think it's should be just one
lump group of humans that let's all vote
on stuff and there's good people
everywhere.
There's good people in Iowa,
there's good people in Kansas is good
people in California.
There's,
you know,
we got to stop all this divisiveness and
I think that's one of the issues that
comes along with people.
I mean there's people that you have
intercity competition,
right?
Fuck Chicago,
you know,
like people get like that.
We get into these teams when it comes to
the United States of America when it
comes to being the president.
I did genuinely think that we have to
look at ourselves as one group of
humans.
Well,
I think we should at least feel like
they are,
that each of our voices counts and we're
in it together that he drove because
right now it's like,
you know,
you live in does it doesn't have a lab
roles.
The east coast or delusional.
They don't have an understanding of the
real people of America.
That voice is horrifying.
Scary voice.
It's a real person out there.
In my head I felt like I was just with a
d,
I had like a moment of like,
what does happen?
Just put my hood on like it.
Well,
I'll show you how to burn a crowd.
You could be like a funny joke.
Meet the funny voice comedian
you with all this.
All this other stuff.
That's fun.
Yeah,
no,
that's A.
Yeah.
I think that we [inaudible] the thing is
I like,
this is one thing I'll say about united
shades when I go to the south side of
Chicago,
we didn't upset about gangs and gang
violence and gang violence in south and
west side of Chicago and I did an
episode apalasia about mostly about coal
and the coal industry and how it's dying
and even people they're note yet to die.
You know when trump comes,
a lot of them cheer because they're
like,
do we just need.
What were they cheering for his jobs?
They're not cheering for coal
necessarily course.
If you said we have other jobs for you,
they'll take those jobs.
Right now.
They do have pride in the culture that
coal,
the coal culture because it's about
their life,
but they're not.
Doesn't have to be that,
but all I'm saying is people in
Appalachian who voted for trump,
people in Chicago who voted for Hillary
are all just worried about jobs and
better schools for their kids and
safety.
Yeah,
John,
they're so,
but when we break it down to this left,
right,
blah,
blah.
It starts to change the conversation
when really there is a party and some
people would say it's the Green party,
but there is up there,
up there,
there is nothing.
You could form a party around those
ideas and not the where these other
parties have gone.
I completely agree.
Well listen man,
I love your show.
I'm glad you're doing it.
I always love talking to you.
We should do this more often.
Absolutely.
Thanks for coming on,
brother.
Thanks for having me.
Tell everybody how they can reach you on
social media.
W Kamau Bell on twitter at Debbie.
Come out,
bill at w w Kamau Bell Dot Com.
I want instagram.
I'm on twitter.
I'm on facebook.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Nice.
Excellent.
Thank you.
Great conversation.
Alright fuckers.
We'll see you tomorrow.